All right, welcome everyone. I will officially
call this meeting to order at 6:03
PM. Um, can we have everyone go
around and state your name, please? Melissa Clark,
City Council. Zach Huish,
City Council. Soraya Farmer, Communications.
Jay Johnson. Steve Mumford. Merrick Burningham.
Cherie Curtis.
Sorry, Don Hamm, Events. Jason Holleran.
Recreation. Jesse Southworth. Awesome. Okay,
thank you. Um, the first thing we have are the approval— is
the minutes from the previous 2 meetings.
Actually, we had the meeting last month and then our special session,
our special meeting for the recreation approvals. Um, were you guys able
to look those over? Yeah. Did anyone have—
there is one correction I know in one of them. It lists
mayor as mayor. That's what happens all the time.
It's one syllable. Yes. So, we have
that correction. Were there any other corrections or anything that needed to
be made? Any issues?
Okay, well, now you guys have to make a
motion instead of Charlotte.
Go ahead. I motion approval of previous 2 meetings' minutes.
I'll second. All right, Cherie made the motion and
Mayor seconded that. Did we have any questions about that?
All in favor?
Aye. And that passes. Okay,
this has a recap
from the previous meeting. I don't think there's anything we really need to talk
about from the last meeting that took forever,
and we'll talk about most of them today, so we'll go ahead and move on
to Sorry,
I'm not prepared, you guys. I'm not doing great today. Maybe the
only update would be the sponsorships, but I think we updated
everyone. We had that special meeting.
Can I mention one thing with that? Absolutely.
Jason's been working with our vendor for making
the Jerseys, and we had a number on the
front, a small number on the front and a big number on the back.
I'll just pull it up real quick, this image.
And the question was, do we need the number on the front?
A lot of cities don't have it, I guess.
That's right. Can you turn this on and put a number
1, input number 1? Once it turns on.
If it turns on. Looks like it might work.
A lot of the soccer clubs don't have a number because
they have the name of the soccer club on the front, you know, like a
logo or something.
But Jason was looking, a lot of cities don't have the number either.
We would just have Anytime Fitness
on the front with our logo since we don't have like another team name.
So I kind of liked the idea of having the number there because then it's
not quite so much just the sponsor,
but it does save us— if we don't do the numbers, it saves about $1,000
total. That's pretty crazy.
Right? That's a lot of money. What if we just made our logo bigger?
Remove the number and made our logo Bigger.
Is it too late? The issue— I think there's an issue. The issue
I would have with that is that it's just supposed to be a badge right
here. I don't know if it would look weird. Yeah, I was just making sure
it's like— But maybe. I mean, you could have the badge bigger and then just
move 5 times further down. Yeah, that's true. What does it look like when they
have the club ones? They're all big. Yeah. Oh,
okay. Yeah. Pulling off the pictures.
Some of them use the whole front of the jersey for their
stuff. Yeah,
our new team is really small. Here's what it looks like on
the big screen with the number. We don't have a
mock-up of without the number. I asked them for one. To me,
I feel like without the number it's almost less busy, but I guess that
doesn't matter. I don't know. Does anyone—
yeah. I will say this personally as a
spectator, not a participant in sports. I like seeing the number
on the front because no matter which way they're going up or down the field,
it's easier to identify the players. So that's the only comment
I have. So,
yeah, this is an example.
Of— it's really small because it's on my phone, but this is an example.
On the big screen there. Sponsor. Yeah,
so that's what it would look like without the number.
Question is, is it worth it to save $1,000 overall?
To have no number there? To have— yeah. I don't think it's necessary.
I agree with Mayor that it is nice, particularly like the
older they are and the busier that it is on the field. But with a
bunch of little kids where it's only 5 on the, you know,
5v5 on the field, it's not that big
that it's hard to recognize what kid is who. Try it without and see
how it goes and consider if it's necessary for another year.
How much is the total bill?
Um, almost,
almost $12,000 with the number on the front, and obviously it's
minus almost $1,000. It's just a whole extra
site that they have to press. So yeah,
how many kids can you sponsor if you don't pay that $1,000 for
If we can pay for
10 more kids to play, then— I think that's a really good
point, Charlotte. I do too.
So I mean, I think saving— because I don't think it makes it look worse,
like it doesn't look less nice or anything, right?
take away from anything. So I would say, I don't
know if we— I don't think we have to. I think that's just a design
decision that Jason makes. So yeah, we have to— so, but there's our input.
So yes, it's my computer.
It seems like I have a computer. The general consensus though is like, it's okay
to not have the number. Okay, yeah, I'll, uh, hopefully they send me another mock-up
in the morning, but they started working And then if you've got a— if
you get complaints, because, you know, I can't see their number,
you know, if you get a lot of complaints, you can go back to putting
it on there. Yeah, we can always add it later. Or just
tell them that you sponsored a whole bunch more kids. That's right. I think most
people would feel really good about that. Sorry.
Yeah.
On that note though, We did discuss some approaches for
seeking out sponsors. So we've got all the jersey sponsors covered, but we don't
have any of the, like, banner sponsors or anything like that.
So that can still happen. So I would say don't
give up. Like, if you know of businesses that might want to, let them know
about it. We didn't— we decided we didn't want to put it
on the website because that— or not on the website. On social media.
On social media. Because we don't want to look like we're Trying
to ask for more money. But I think
if you word it in such a way, it doesn't look like we're needy and
need the money. You can just be like, hey businesses, if you want an opportunity
to advertise, come help our rec department
and be a sponsor. I don't think the citizens are gonna be like,
oh, it's cheap, a cheap city trying to— yeah, I think
if you word it right and it's, it's more geared to businesses, not the individual
citizen, It might be a good way to get others out of the woodwork that
maybe wouldn't see it, you know, from commerce or whatever.
It might be good to do it on LinkedIn because a lot of
businesses look for stuff like that on LinkedIn as opposed
to Facebook. Does Eagle Mountain have— does the city
have a LinkedIn? Yeah, yeah. It's also a
good angle to, you know, instead of saying, you know, sponsor us,
it's help kids, you know, help kids play. Yeah, yeah,
exactly. That's a very good point.
If you want us to post on LinkedIn, should they
just email Jason like before, like email rec,
or what would you want? The contact for someone?
There's, I mean, yes. It's right on there. There's a link. Yeah.
Do you have that advertisement? I don't know if
I do. Kyle might have it, but unfortunately he's not here right now, so if
you could send it to me. Oh, is it what we— oh, okay. I think
we just put your contact information. Is that okay with you? Okay.
Well, in the email on it was like rec. Yeah.
And that one's okay? Instead of J-Hall?
Okay, cool. Thank you. That's a good idea.
Um, when would you want a post? Is that like as soon as possible,
or— I think so, yeah. Okay, that would be awesome.
Um, we did— there was a football
banner up on the pickleball courts for a while, but that has
officially been taken down. And so I think if you guys ever see
unauthorized banners up there, who should
we— how should we handle that if we see them? Should we just put it
in the app? Put it in the app and Neighborhood Improvement will get assigned to
take it down. Yeah, just in the— well, I just called Jim and told him,
and he, he went over there and took it down.
On that note, you should have to put in the app too. If there's anything
you see at a park that needs fixing, like maintenance
type thing, or a trail that needs whatever,
instead of bringing it into this group,
just those fixes, just put it in the portal on the app.
Our parks crews will handle it. I use that app
all the time. And they're gonna get super annoyed at They haven't gotten
mad at me yet. I mean, maybe they have, they just don't talk about
it. Not out loud. You're the one that says anonymous.
I can't because the council has to log in. Oh, put anything
in there. So you guys, if I put something in, you know it.
Um, last night was the off-street trails
plan. Was that— has that all been passed now? Yeah. That was
approved. Great. So then the next steps are trying
to get some money. And, and just FYI,
if I didn't tell you last time, I, I met with Ty Shepherd with
the Lake Mountain Trails Association.
Adam, who was involved with that, is still on the board but no longer the
president. And so Ty's not the president either.
Cam Wixom is the president, but he lives in Saratoga Springs. So Ty volunteered
who lives up there on O'Wahii,
Skyline Ridge, and he's awesome. He's a firefighter
with Salt Lake City Fire,
and his wife is also on the, on the board as
well, and he's involved with the high school team and
another group, a biking group as well.
Anyway, I met with him a couple times. He produced
a A first-year work
proposal for— that goes along with
our MOU, our Memorandum of Understanding with Sitla
that I'm working on to be able to get access, legal access to all
the trails on their property up in the Hidden Valley area.
So we're getting close on that. We got that over to Sitla last night.
They're excited to work with us, but Sedla is Sedla,
and they may end up wanting to make more changes
to the agreement and a bunch of other things. Just imagine like the slowest government
possible and then multiply it by 10. Experience that
one. But we are making progress on that, and they
were— he was excited about— they came last night again to see the off-street trails
plan approved.
And I asked them— so
let me step back. The goal is to have the Lake Mountain Trails Association be
mainly responsible for maintenance of these trails and cleaning the properties
and everything up in that whole Hidden Valley area. And they're good with
that. And they'll have a plan each year for which trails they want to
improve. And he said they're gonna focus
this year on not creating new trails. But adding a couple of little connections,
but then focusing on maintaining the safety, improving the safety and
rideability of the trails. And are they going to come directly to council
for funding? Or is that going to be a WRAP application?
I think generally, they will collect their own money,
they'll get donations. And they've been able to do that before.
But we would want to partner with them on some projects and be able to
use some city, whether it's RAP tax or other funding,
and some of their money. For instance, we budgeted—
we have, I believe, in our capital projects—
I'm trying to remember if it's the capital— I think it's in the utility sale
proceeds. There's about $70,000 set aside for
the bike park specifically. Specifically for expansion and fixing and
other things. We can,
we can work with Lake Mountain Trails on figuring out
what to do there, but I think ultimately we'll need
to hire a firm to do a better design— not a better, a next step,
next level design for a phase 1 of that,
and then determine how much that costs and how For
the wayfinding signs, is that separate
from what the Lake Mountain Trails Association is doing? The ones
where we were gonna put how far and what
the name of the trail is and all of that? So there are some signs
up there already that look pretty nice, but we can still
modify it and change to look more like the plan shows. But Ty's actually
the one that made those. And they have the name
of the trail, and then they have the logo of the city, and the logo
of Lake Mountain Trails Association, and the difficulty level.
Not sure about the distance, they might. And then he was going
to add Sitla's logo to the ones on Sitla property because that's what they wanted.
And he said, I would still make those and
put them up. Trading cards. I think he was using his own money for that.
I told them, well, let's work together and figure out a solution. So,
I think it's a good idea though to be able to get some wayfinding signs
early in Phase 1. When we get those,
um, like when we need to like hire a
firm or something, is it— how do you advertise that you
need, that we need one of those? Do you guys reach out to people
yourself? Like, how does that work? Just depends on the The cost.
So if it's under— yeah, I have to pull it up,
but if it's within a certain amount, we just need to go
get some bids from up
to 3 different companies. Do you just choose random companies?
Don't you have to post it on the RFP? You only do if it's above
a certain— oh, certain cost. Yeah. But you have to get at least 3.
Yeah. So that's kind of— I just always wonder if there's— because I feel like
there's a lot of things that get hired out that people
locally could do that don't know that. So, if it's some
wayfinding signs, and we're only doing 5 of them or something,
it'll be under that cost threshold. Right. We may not even need
3 official bids if it's low. If it's under $5,000, I don't know that we
need even that. But, if it's over $5,000, I think you need 3 bids.
And, if it's just a bid, you have to go with who has the lowest
bid. Correct? No. Oh, nope, not on that. Not on something
like that. Okay, good. All right.
Um, cool. Was there any other
things that have— like any other current projects or things
that— or things that have happened in the last month that
we needed to— anything that we talked about? I don't think I saw anything.
We went to the farmers market again. And Charlotte
and Jesse were there and gave out more free stuff.
It was great. There were 2 park benches put in
Sage Valley Park, just random showed up. I was like, oh, Ronnie.
So was that— I was gonna ask, are the same park benches being put
in at, uh, Smith Ranch? Like, that was a
more specific one. I asked about those like 3 years ago. Oh, you did?
So come back in 3 years. There we go.
It took me 9 years to get Smithfield.
With that list that we recommended,
has the council like officially gotten that
list? And no, like, what list? So that, that list only
went out in an email to the council and mayor as
an update on what happened with our Community Services Board meeting last time.
And so I'm thinking about how do we officially
present those to the council. With our,
like, we have recommendations that we have things that we would like, that we think
should be priorities and get done right now. Would you like it, like, do we
need to do it in an official capacity at a council meeting?
Well, I think because everybody keeps saying just bring us the prioritization.
Well, we have it. That's what we're talking about. Bring it to a
work session, wouldn't you say, Steve? We could set it up on a work session.
We got the information to you quickly. Do we know how we're
proposing to pay? We were told to just give you
a list. Here's my thoughts. Let's wait until after August 18th
to bring our wish list to City Council, and then we
can discuss it. Why?
Why would you wait till after August 18th?
Because there's already criticism of what we're spending money on.
It's just like, we have money for— Well, that's why,
but like, because Steve sent it in an email, so if this— does it need
to come in an official meeting, or can I— I'm just— what would
make it actionable? Would it be, here are the projects, here's the estimated
cost per project, kind of like we did with the— That's what we need.
Bigger capital projects. So do we have dollars assigned to each of those? I can—
I'll work with, um, with our Parks Department and get numbers.
To go with it. Okay. And then that'd be the only thing
we need is the priority list. I'll talk on Monday with— how many things are
on that list? It was only like 8 or so.
Okay. It was a small list because it was things that the
board thought could be implemented fairly quickly, I think. One of them
goes along with one of the things you were talking about for the community block
grant last night. It was ADA compliance. Yes, at a couple
of parks. So that one you could actually knock out with the community block grant
if that's what you choose to do with it. There's a couple parks that reported
that they weren't ADA compliant, and so the— what's
actually on our list is that we— We can just say that this door's open.
No, we have to leave one open. We'll close this for now.
What we, what we said on the list was that these,
I think it's 2, are not compliant, so we need to take care of those.
But we also said that staff should see, you know,
look at our other parks to see what others need done. In that case,
I think you should bring it sooner. I was thinking that it was like the
dream big stuff. No, the small stuff. The small,
quick, affordable stuff. So let me— I'll get numbers. I'll talk to Parks
Department. I'll talk to Ben on Monday, and we'll figure out the best way to—
So we just have to get a project price. Budget, I think we'll be fine.
It's like benches and curbs and— Easy.
Some of it, like benches, for instance, we could probably fit that into the
current parks budget and just take care of it. And just a little sign
next to the bench, brought to you by the Community Services Board. I love it.
What do you think? No, I, I think that— I think
that stuff will just sell through. Well, especially stuff that we have to use
community development block grant funds for. We have leftovers from last year, so let's
ADA this place on up. Like, what are we waiting for? Did that include the
art for the electrical boxes? Was that in that? That was on that
list. That was on that list, that's what I thought. But that does— I don't
think that falls in this. Doesn't Rocky Mountain Power pay? There was a program.
You design it and they pay the art for it. Well,
I was— we had been talking about the ADA, so that's what I was connecting
it to. It's not— it's not ADA or
the low income either. But yes, Rocky Mountain Power has.
But the ADA rates should be eligible.
How long until the Walmart one's gonna happen? Because that's one of the most crucial
ones that I've heard people— We're starting that one soon. Okay. Because I thought about
that all last night when they were talking about it. I was like— But he
said there it's already Funded, so we can't use the— No, I know. I was—
yes. So the priority list, we'll just have numbers,
bring it to the work session, kind of work through it with
the council, and then if it's all good to go— I would also say,
so what the list is, what the dollar amount is, and what
funds we can use for them. So if it's eligible for
community development, or if it's eligible for parks funding,
that's helpful for us because then we know there's already money
to cover it. So we have any— Steve, I'm just curious, were you able to
get updated cost signs? Interpretive signs? It does start in April, but it's at
the end of each of the quarters. So we will get it. I think we've
got our first one. And do you remember that? Yeah, I think so. That was
part of our— it was one of the stipulations.
Saratoga Springs waited an entire year before they even talked about If we
didn't— they have a high cost. I mean, a high
estimate, right? And they actually cost less. Yeah,
they're very— they're a lot more expensive than they had in that plan. So,
like, they had $400, and that covers nothing, basically.
Okay,
so I think that covers everything we talked about last meeting and things
that went on. So, let's Let's move on to what
the communications team has for us this week. Yay!
Just me. No. Hi, I'm Soraya. I don't know
if I've met all of you, or I've probably seen you around, you've probably seen
me around, but just wanted to say hi. I'm the digital communications
specialist. I work a lot with Kyle Ireland. You might have seen him around
as well. We just wanted to come to this meeting— we—
I just wanted to come to this meeting, sorry.
just to see how we can all work together, how we can best help you.
And, um, I wanted to say I just got your
business card and the scorpion hunt was like a huge hit. I don't know if
you helped with that at all, but— It was. We have a great turnout.
That was a huge hit. Like, people were losing their minds.
They were so happy. Um, our like social media posts about it did
really incredible. I was a little
skeptical because scorpions kind of scare me, just being 100% honest.
Um, but like, this was an incredible— Eagle Mountain has a dark side,
and we found that whenever we do creepy crawly things
like snakes and scorpions and spiders and so forth,
people come. That's— the whole room out here was packed.
Yeah. I saw the photos. I wanted to go with my son and we
couldn't make it work. Well, everyone keeps commenting, um,
wondering when we're doing it again. So if, if we are doing it again,
we're happy to That was like the 4th one we've done. Yeah.
Oh really? They've all been really well attended. The first 2, I think they had
to do at the chamber office because no one in City Hall would let them
do it over here. There's a new sheriff in town.
Yeah. I think I've never even heard that we did it.
Yeah. Yeah, I did not know until this morning. Because they had like 98 people
show up to the chamber office, which it doesn't hold 98 people,
but— Do you know where they actually went to do it?
Well, they've done Hidden Canyon the last few times that I was aware
of it, but I don't know where they went this one time. I wasn't here,
so I'm not sure exactly where they went. Hidden Canyon is where they've gone before,
and there's parking over there because there's a trailhead. Anyway, there's just—
I'll ask Dana if you want to know. We should
do like a team building activity with the Community Services Board where we go find—
I've actually done it, but I'd really rather not.
I don't want anyone out. Just take it back to my yard.
You'd be surprised. I don't want to do that. Get you a black flashlight and
go out in your own neighborhood. Any sense of place? Yes.
Ignorant. Ignorant, thank you. I thought you said— No, no,
no, you're good. Um, I was just gonna say if there's any like events you
want us to help promote, we're always happy to post that on our social media.
Just try to give us as much time as possible just because it takes
a little bit of time to make graphics or write a blog post or whatever
we we need to do, but we're super happy to help however we can.
You can send it all to Steve and he can send it to us,
or I don't know what the best, like, workflow— That's what I was going to
ask, is do we contact you directly or do we go through Steve? I think,
um, I think for now talk to me. Okay. Yeah, and then I'll get it
over and work with them. I talk to them every day anyways. We are working
on a big— we're working on a big project that we were looking
at working with EM-SERV, We're going to need a lot of volunteers come
like October, November-ish. We have thousands
of sagebrush seedlings to plant for habitat restoration.
I can let you know more specific dates as we come
to them. So we're working— yeah. You should just trick people into coming here.
You tell them it's a scorpion hunt. Yeah.
To find the scorpions, care to dig this hole up in this That's a great
idea. You'll have a huge turnout.
Bait and switch. That's so funny.
Service after dark. Notice if you bury that creepy crawly in
the hole. That'd be amazing. Make sure you take pictures and tag
us on Facebook. Oh my gosh, that's funny. No, we're super happy to help,
like, however we can. Like, our team's here to help.
Photos, video, blog posts, on our calendar.
Newsletter. We have a lot of different channels of media,
so however we can best help you, we're here for you. You guys are doing
really well. Oh, thank you, thank you. We're trying, trying really hard. Somebody was
telling me how much better our comms department is than Saratoga, and they weren't
wrong. Oh, thank you. I think you're doing really great work.
We're trying, but we can always be better, so however we can best,
like, support everyone else, that's That's why we're here, to support the community
and do really fun events. Um,
is there anything like besides what you just mentioned,
this, the sagebrush, and then also posting, um, about the
recreation, um, sponsorship opportunities, is there anything else
at the moment that we can help with or any other upcoming projects that,
um, we could add to our list? Yeah, would it be possible For
you guys to create something that says Community Services Board so that if we
go to like Shop Fest, we have a legit looking thing. You know,
I, I don't want a banner. You're talking like a banner? Yeah, like a 1-foot
or 2-foot banner so they can hang it up in front of like a regular
sign for it. I didn't have a banner, but— Well, we have money for banners.
I'm not in charge of budgets. You donate a ton of your time. Confirm that.
Sorry, the Community Services I think— Has a budget. Okay, go ahead
and design something. Yeah. And I'll send it to Steve. I'll use
your budget for it. Wait, what? Put it on paper too
for different things, like just the— A logo? Like a logo for just
to show— Or like the E that says Community Services by
it, just like we have one for parks and other stuff. Like, it doesn't have
to be— Probably do that. One thing we're working on, I don't know,
Steve, maybe you can help whether this is appropriate or
not, but we will have the Tod A. Black Scholarship
sponsorship campaign coming up soon,
and we're hopeful that the city might be able to help
us advertising for— The city will help advertise
for the Tod Black Scholarship. We're very familiar with that.
We're looking for— to encourage people to donate.
It's going to be an endowed scholarship, we hope. It's at
Utah State University. Utah State University. Yeah,
so we're hoping to be able to
award the first scholarship spring of 2027 for
their spring semester. So yeah,
I mean, I don't see why not. I can send
you materials and Yeah, going into biological research. I think— I
don't see why we'd say no. It'd be nice. So I'm saying yes. It'd be
nice to have that sort of support in the city because we can accept,
you know, small donations from residents that may have interacted with Todd
or have students that are interested in that sort of thing,
as well as corporate sponsors or donors. So yeah,
I think— thanks. On that note though, I do have
a question in In regards to the sponsorship things, when we get— because
it's probably for you guys— when we get sponsors for those banners, do we
want to have them like just their logo, or is this something
that we want like to have a design that their logo fits onto so
that all the banners look nice? Is that some— do we care about
that? How— what would you guys prefer, that if there are banners on our pickleball
courts that they look a certain way? I think it's just like, Yes,
yeah, yes please. Um, yeah, you can just send them our way and
we're happy to design something. So if we get their logos and we'll give them
to you guys? Yeah.
What we have to do with economic development signs, for the
ladder signs that are around the city, they just have to get approved by the
economic development director. So maybe as a part of your policy that you write,
we figure out whatever staff member is the one that signs off on them,
because that way we can have like a process for them. Yeah, with most the
recreation stuff, most of the sponsorship stuff, Jason and basically
Jason and Jesse. Yeah, he was in The Devil Wears Prada, so he knows a
ton about design. Were you really? Is that really your legs?
I was like, who were you? I watched that recently,
actually. I'm like, were you— that would happen.
Maybe you were an extra. That would actually be really cool.
It's my side view. So for the record, she said
yes, he was in Buried. And show us your
legs. And it flopped. Oh dear.
You're an actual movie star. We have a real movie star here. Oh,
he really was. That's actually really cool.
No way. Oh nice. It flopped,
but— But you can still say it. It's still good to watch.
It's still watchable. I got to meet him. It was a good time. That's why
Jay's on this board. For the star power. We need at least one.
Yeah. But yeah, any design needs you want or
anything you need on social media or our website, just make sure to
reach out to our team. We're happy to help. So what we, what we don't
necessarily want is the
board or individual board members directing the communications Right.
Put this out, put this out, put this out. Kind of an advisory board.
Yes. Now you do make decisions on, on some funding
and sponsor— sponsorships and stuff, but, um,
but what we don't want to do is like limit it either, and, and for
me to be telling you no. Um, so don't overdo
it with posts all the time, but if
there are needs, then let's— they're here to help Would you
prefer, like, the board all discuss it and it come from
me to you, or how do you— I
mean, I think we'll all be in agreement with it all, so it should be
fine. I think that things should always go through the chair,
because if someone comes back and says, what's going on with this,
you deserve to be able to know and be able to speak to it.
So I think that's a good process. We don't have to wait and talk about
everything in a meeting. necessarily, right, for a post. But yeah, if we
want to advertise, if we have an event coming up, we want to advertise for
it, that's not a standard city event.
Converse with Jesse and Jesse will get it to Steve.
Yes. Sounds good. That sounds like a great process to me.
And then Steve will get it to us. But we'll all get it. As long
as it doesn't end up like the telephone game. Yeah, we have a good
concept. That's awesome. No, we're trying to like— It'll
turn into a scorpion hunt every time.
That's what we're gonna do for Truth in Taxation.
I'm here for the scorpion!
It'll be awesome. But we love
our wildlife, so. Anything else? Anything else that you've
been thinking of that— Anything else we can Communications can help us
with. Do we have any other events? We haven't— Charlotte,
did you need help promoting something? Um, it's not till September 2nd,
and then there will be one probably in the next couple weeks after that,
um, because we have the, um,
pop-up museum at Cedar Valley for America
250, um, on September 2nd. And then
sometime between then, I need to get with the school to book that one,
but sometime between the 2nd and the 17th,
we'll do the Constitution boot camp also at Cedar Valley. So,
so I won't bug you quite yet, but how far in advance do you like
to have those? Honestly, as soon as you have all the
info, at least maybe 2 weeks before, if that's
I mean, I understand sometimes there's like last-minute things, so if it does need to
be last minute, we can do it, but just as much time as possible.
I'm assuming in writing is better, so I'll send an email to Jesse who can
send it to Steve, who will send it to you. I know it's kind of
a lengthy process, but— Or just send it to Jesse and me at the
same time. Oh yeah, visibility.
I'll get the date for the second event so I can send both in one
email. Because they'll be within a couple weeks of each other.
So I'll get that and then I'll send that over.
I just have a lot of amazing people that I work with
and a lot of different projects, so just as soon as possible is why I
say that. We have so many cool things going on.
That's true. Awesome. Well,
thank you. Is there anything else?
Anything you need from us? Questions?
I don't think so. I don't know. I know you
were messaging us about like the walk-through. Do you have anything?
I'll talk about that in just a bit. Yeah, I don't know. Are you sticking
around for the— or are you leaving soon? Um, whatever you need.
Well, don't say it. Get it out of the way
now. Yeah, um,
I, I'm not sure if you wanted our input. I don't know if you have
any input on that at all, or if there's anything else you need from us.
Otherwise, I'm good. So, uh,
we'll talk about it
as a board. And then bring it back. But, um, we will want your help.
Like promoting? Promoting it, and figure out what the best way to
do that is. And yes.
Sounds good to me. For the Walk 30 and the treasure hunt and And
then the Constitution camps and these other things that were— that
are not like standard city events. And then do we have—
do we have it when you scan the QR code on our bingo
card? Does it actually take us to a list of additional activities,
or do we need to create that? No answer. Okay, I think it goes to
like our calendar, so they can just go to find anything,
any of the, any of the events that we have. Um,
if there's anything we need to add to that calendar, please let us know as
well. But we have— I feel like we have so many good events.
Hopefully they'll find at least one. Something to get to. Yeah,
we have a lot. I just wanted to make sure we weren't sending them
to nowhere when they scan that QR code. Um,
we can make like an updated post if you want, like about
the bingo, like, hey, if you missed any of the events, go to our website,
look at the community calendar, any of these events count.
That way they know what happens when they scan that QR code.
And why they were taken to a calendar. They're like, what?
Thank you for the calendar. Melissa, did you have something? Yeah, so related
to comms, I think while we're waiting for RAP tax
dollars and RAP tax projects to get visibility and like actually
exist. If there's anything that the comms department thinks
that like they can almost do like a man on the street or something
like the stuff that Charlotte's doing or
the bingo card, I think that all the people who serve on Community Services
Board could ultimately be a cool person in one
of your reels. So I'm volunteering all of them. As long as you're okay
with it. If you don't want to be on social media— You're all okay.
Not Jessie, but everyone else. She likes to post.
She doesn't like to be in the— I like to be behind the camera.
Charlotte's our salesperson. I think us giving a face to—
because that was a big deal to people to pass the route tax, is that
their neighbors, the residents of Eagle Mountain, would help guide that process.
So I think it's a neat way to help fill the space
between now and when projects actually get accomplished. And we laughed about it when
we talked about, you know, saying brought to you by the Community Services Board,
but I actually think that when we do projects with the RAP tax, we really
should have some kind of a plate or something on them that says paid for
by your RAP tax dollars, because then people can see
that it actually did something. That's a great idea. That's a requirement too. If somebody
writes for a grant with you guys, they have to show how they're going to
demonstrate that it came from the RAP tax. But anyway, I just think
giving it a human face and letting people see that these are the residents that
are representing them is kind of a cool thing to do. Once we do have
benches at Smith Ranch Park, oh my gosh, we should go do a video that
says, hey— No, let's do it to like a trendy song.
Oh my gosh, perfect. Like the Full House
music. It shows like a bunch of you
at the bench. We need some before and
after though. We need footage with no benches and looking around trying
to find— It could be really candid, like with those Jib
Jab videos with just our faces on cut out. You know what
I mean? Have you seen the Jib Jab videos?
Schedules. Like, I can do reels, but I
would say my coworker Ashley is just— that's more her forte.
Like, we all, I feel like, are really good at everything, but I
would say she's the best at that. So maybe if we can schedule a time
when she's working, um, I think that would be the best.
Okay. All right, that's awesome. Thank you so much. Anything else?
If not, then we will go ahead and
move on. And first off, again, thank you for coming and being here for us.
Thank you, Soraya. You guys really are great. It was nice to meet you,
by the way. I've never met you before. Yes, thank you.
Yeah, thanks to the name. All right,
now we will go on and move to the Healthy Utah Community
Designation, and we'll
turn the time over to Steve. I forgot in
the very beginning to— did I excuse Steve Conger and Liz? No, excuse me.
I was gonna say, do I need to— do I need to note that I
entered? Sorry for Sorry for being late. It's all good. Charlotte Dukos
is here. And I meant to excuse Steve and
Liz, and I forgot to do that. Now you
may go. We'll show that in the minutes.
Okay, um, see if my computer,
when I rebooted, if it got everything back. Okay, now we'll see
if this works. And if
not, that is okay, because it's not like I have anything amazing
to show you.
So we did send out— Jesse sent out some ideas
for Healthy Utah.
And Yeah,
it looks like it may not do it. What's the issue?
I don't know.
Is it all plugged in? It's plugged in. We were
having issues with stuff yesterday. I wonder if part of it is because we switched
over to Zoom in here and we're still figuring things out because— We do have
a pretty cool new system for the video. I'm gonna just direct plug into
the HDMI port on the TV. That's what he was doing.
No, that could be. I mean, that one is plugged into the TV and we've
always used it that way, but— Do you want to unplug it from here and
then just plug it into the TV?
The port is at the top somewhere. Are you sure?
Weird. None of those are on. It's okay. We don't— I don't have a lot
to show, so We should have put
a clip of Paunch Burger and a child-sized soda
on Parks and Recreation because that would have been a hilarious lead-in
to Healthy Utah designation. Would be.
True missed opportunity.
Did you guys all get a chance to look over the email we sent about—
Yes. Thank you,
by the way. I appreciate it. I feel like I sent a
lot of lengthy things this month. That's good to have.
It's probably— it's— I think it's right below this on the back,
but all right, it's okay. You sure?
Yeah. Okay, I can print out, uh, a couple of these if
we need to. No, you can't. We know you can't print.
Liar! He moved over to the other building. He's forgotten how to do anything over
here. My computer forgot how to do everything. I don't
know how to do it. You guys are on Windows. Come on.
Let's see if this works.
I know, I hate Windows. Yeah, I think it is printing. We should see.
Okay.
We have the 3— What we need to do is identify 9 strategies
that we have already implemented or are currently implementing and
then identify 3 more that we— at
least 3 more that we want to work on each
year, this next year. And I'm
going to check the printer real quick. Talk amongst yourselves. I'll tell
you a little bit about this because when— oh, sorry. Every year when
we go to ULCT for our annual conference for Utah League of Cities and
Towns, they call up all these cities and they get this
designation. And I've been asking for this for like 3 years.
I'm totes excited that it's finally happening because we already
do most of the things on it. We just have to formalize it.
Just to say that we're helping? We're gonna make a sticker
that has like bodybuilding on it and the E. Little sneaker.
The E will wear sneakers. It'll be so good.
Ignore the check marks on this because that's just what's on their website. I don't
know why. I don't know why they have check marks. It was weird. So yeah,
they have check marks on it. Showing you what you need to do. I was
like, did somebody like go in and— Maybe
those are ones that you have to do. Are there certain ones you have to
do? No, you just have to do 3 for each category. And we actually,
um, the funny thing is we have so many active living things, but,
um, like some of them are in
like in progress. They're not implemented, and it says they have
to be fully implemented, right? So that
like? Well, organize a free or low-cost fitness event for your community. Turkey trot.
That one's done. Yeah, that one's done. But the, the active transportation,
the off-street trails master plan is scheduled. So that's done now.
So we can— yep. Do we have to have done the things on it?
Or do we just have to have approved it? That's the question. What about
building the Smithfield? It's not Smithfield.
Smith Ranch. Yeah, that was the first one in the city.
We should Throw that on there. Let's see. Yeah, for sure.
I don't know how long, like, yeah, how far in the past.
Yeah, yeah, no, that's all back. Okay, well, when you just— active living
list to find 3. Well, well, let's see. Oh, Steve has a
presentation. I just have the ones that we sent out is all, which I'm
trying to pull up again. So I
mean, we have the annual turkey trot. If we
can count the off-street trails master plan because it's been approved, then that's
our second one. And then we have for your low-cost community sports.
Yeah, well, okay, that's the other thing is, have— do
we actually have scholarships available already now?
Well, it has to be— it's low cost, says it is. I mean, yeah,
it has to be implemented. We've used— do we— I promise you
that we've had low-cost stuff for a long time. I feel like that's an
easy check. It's just rec. We have rec sports. Yeah. And I think that counts.
Don't we have an active transportation plan already?
I thought that got passed like in the 20— We have a
bike and pedestrian master plan. That counts. That one's checked too.
All of our schools have safe routes. It was quite a while ago. All our
schools have safe routes. Who's doing the yoga or tai chi or whatever in the
park already? The library. Our library does yoga in the park. See,
that's why we could get this both times over. I mean,
based on like what Steve sent me and what I've then sent
out to you guys after I went through it, um, it's— we have more than
3 in each category. Yeah, I just wasn't— the only one I
wasn't sure on, because we have tons in the others, the only one I wasn't
sure on is the things that we are actively like working on right now.
But I didn't know if it counted if they were just approved or if
they had to like actually be done.
So, but if it just needs to be approved to be done, like there is
a plan for it, then yeah, we were easy on all of them.
Where did we land with the revitalization?
That's one of the things that's on the recommendation. Well,
it's on one of the recommendations from them. And I think we've already
budgeted $70,000 for Yeah, that's what he said. And that's
in the off-street trails plan. The plan
that you approved last night? Yep. And I think if you partner with Lake Mountain
Trails Association, you can get extra money too. Plus there's
big businesses that want to write blank checks to us, so let's get that.
And in the meantime, they can write it to the Trails Association and
say it needs to go towards this park. Yep, all of it.
So which 3 do you want to identify?
If we identify too many, then we can't use those again next
year. Probably so. So what are the ones that we have
had the longest so that we can use more recent ones later? We could do
the Turkey Trot, the free or low-cost community sports programs.
The second to the last one, that's the implement one new worksite wellness strategy.
Our city does something, they have Wellness Wednesdays and they you something
new every week. So like, that's an easy checkmark. Wait,
are you on the Active Living? It's the last one.
One new work site. Are you guys on the other page? Oh, I'm on a
different page. Sorry everyone. Yeah, I didn't know that we're— sorry. Oh, I only got
the front. Yeah, I only got one too. Yeah, sorry. Me too. She just—
she had the one that I resent. Oh, you probably— sorry, different. It's my fault.
But the city does that one. That's a clear easy one.
Yeah, another easy one would be the safe routes. Yeah,
all of the schools have that.
So, yep. Well, this is something you do every year to
get— No, isn't it every 2 or 3 years? So it says that you have
to,
um, 3 additional— so
the city must identify 3 additional strategies to implement over the next 3 years.
Oh, okay. And they can come from any of the 3 categories. Well, and there's
some on here already that are like going to be done within the next 18
months, so I think like the wayfinding signage. Yep.
So, I just need to keep track of what
we do. So, you need to officially— did we already officially designate
us as the health coalition? I don't think so.
Wouldn't that be in a resolution when we turn this in? Like the council will
do a resolution of that? We can do that.
Yes. Just do it all at the same time. We need to— so we will
have to submit this before we do that? Yeah. It's due
August. Will there be a problem post-dating?
Are they going to verify when this got passed through council?
I'm a hard no on this one.
Seriously? We'll do what we can to,
uh— Let me guess, the soda. The sugar tax. Yeah, I don't
drink sugar, but still, no, hard pass. I think there was
one on, um, yeah, I believe in freedom
of choice. I try to say soda.
Okay, what about the community food system plan?
So are we making— okay, did you get the ones that you needed? So for
the, for the first section, they have the Turkey Trot, Safe Routes
to Schools, the off-street trails master
plan, and bike and ped master plan. We also have the workplace
worksite wellness. Do we have to submit like proof No.
No. Just the letter of commitment. And are you
going to be doing this, the letter of commitment, or do you need me to
do it? No, I can prepare it. And I'll send
it to you to review. And then what we'll do
is we'll send it, we'll send it to the council.
And Let them know that we will be
submitting this, and if there are any concerns, tell us immediately. But otherwise,
we'll submit it and we'll have the council do a resolution and,
and, uh, awesome,
say yes.
Okay, so you got the 3 that you need? Normally we would follow a better
process, but yeah, we have the 3 for action. of living and healthy
foods. There's no shame in how we're doing this.
So the second one, establish a farmers market that
accepts SNAP. We're good on that one. So it does accept SNAP? Yeah,
it does. We already have a seed exchange.
We sure do. In the library.
And we already have a pantry at the library. Yes.
We also already have ordinances that allow 3 or
other animals. So if you're going for 4 instead of 3 to be
the overachievers, those 4 are already easy.
Well, we did improve access to emergency food by establishing
the food pantry program. That's one. Yeah.
Oh, sorry, I was reading it. Maybe I shouldn't drink sugar-sweetened
I have that. If I'm writing notes, I can't hear what's being said.
So yeah, I think the backyard poultry animal
husbandry ordinances, the SNAP
at the farmers market, the library
pantry— I think those are all— those are good ones. And I think that
one of our 3 that we want to implement over the next
3 years is I think that we should identify those junk pieces of property in
different areas of our city and make them into— make ones
that make sense into community gardens for that area.
Or a food forest. Yeah.
We've actually had that suggestion before because they're like— there's an area by Walden Park,
and I just don't know how that works
in Practice. I don't know how you can even— We've actually done it.
We've actually done it a couple of times. Yeah, and it was a miserable failure.
Hasn't worked, but doesn't mean it won't. There are places that do,
in other cities that have made it work. I just— I mean, you look at
those, those little libraries, right? Yeah. And the kids just come and
destroy them. That's gonna happen. Well, that's why it's got to be community-based. It needs
to be like— don't they have community gardens up in Eagle Heights? Because that was
part of their approach. for their open space credit. They wanted credit
for doing community gardens up there. I know that there's some in the Saratoga-Lehigh area
as well. I think that would be a good idea in general to be able
to have credit for establishing community— open space credit. Because you
just need water. For establishing community gardens in neighborhoods.
That is the thing is, yeah, you'd have to have water. They would have to
put water to it and then you would divide them into like Specific sizes.
Was that not— No, what I was just thinking is
what would be good is if you guys looked at— if you
did some research on what a community garden would need and then brought to the
City Council what the recommendations and requirements are,
so that if we gave credit for open space— You understood.
Because criteria— to Steve's point, we've done stuff like
that to check a box and say we've got edible gardens here as a city,
and they were just garbage within a year. Yeah. So like, if we had
requirements of what was— We also need to focus in on areas
that don't have enough of their own land because— Yeah,
in my neighborhood, right, nobody needs it. Right. You know,
in Zach's neighborhood, nobody needs it.
That's actually a really good idea for that, that strip of Nolan
Park that's along Peregrine because that gets watered with sprinklers,
so it wouldn't be hard to do a community garden, right? And it's right there
by the condos. That's right. So that's what we would be looking for is high
population areas that don't have their own
ground to put it in. Is there an active request from residents that
want to do those kinds of gardens? We get one like probably once
every 2 years where they come in and ask for us to do it and
nothing's— Those that ask, are they actually going to be the
wants to put forth. Chris Deep even wanted to manage it. We have
community garden boxes over at the senior center. Oh, those count. And we
can, we can put in more along that strip of the trail.
And the seniors love to like garden and take
out— because that's a great idea. And residents actually garden and we'll help them occasionally
and they'll take the vegetables. We need to know more that that's possible.
So there's another one in Saratoga, it's a 65-plus
community or 55-plus community that Pepperdine Homes did, and it has
a giant one and it gets used. I was going to say, I love that
idea with the seniors because that could help qualify for mental health. But in
the areas that are big enough that they have seniors,
youth, or others, I think that would be
a really good idea. They also don't have To
your point, they don't have the option to garden because it's an HOA and they
can't do any of that. Yeah, so our apartment complexes and
condos, that's where we need to— You know what, also open
spaces there. I'm just gonna— right now in our code for multifamily,
they're required to do a clubhouse and a pool. And the pool
is kind of arbitrary, but if there was a significant exchange
Instead of the pool, and it was a really nice community garden,
and it was managed by their HOA, whatever, that could be a
substitute. There was a group that came to us and they asked to
put cornhole there and a grill. Yeah, it was ridiculous. In exchange for a pool.
It was the dumbest request we've ever gotten, but— But it's
okay, they made up for it by coming 5 times.
person came for a— but no, look, fitness center is the
one. Their fitness center was like one treadmill.
And it was certain members of council I
don't think would approve even a garden in exchange for a pool. But I think
if you guys— Depends on if it was built right. Right. I think if you
guys dig in and you set the requirements and you come up with kind of
a foolproof way to have community gardens, and this is the requirements that
gets presented it to council, council adopts that as an alternate
for the pool of requirements. And I want to add, looking at this, I— at
community gardens for my own list, that there were
a number of places, cities and towns, that had
very successful community gardens that I was looking at. So you could draw
a lot from what's work that's already been
done. The other option is to make the— make it the option
of available, let the community know that that's something that they can put in if
they've got land and the desire. And then it goes to places where
they've applied and they want it. And then you know that they're going to— Are
they all 100% community-driven, or is there someone that kind of goes
in and— Chris Diep even brought one because he wanted
to manage it. He wanted to buy the land behind my house and do that
kind of stuff there. Well, he didn't even necessarily want to buy it, but he
wanted us to be able to do community gardens there. So like,
there's— there are some people that spearhead it. We had a mayor
that was very pro-permaculture,
where like you bury wood and stuff and you grow out of that. So that's
where some of the community— when Penker was here, he did that. And we had
Caleb Warnock come out and do a consultation, and he's a big gardening
guy. We had a greenhouse programmed into Cory-Ride
Park in one of the phases in the initial design, because I was
on Parks and Rec when we did that. So like, it's possible, it just
hasn't been spearheaded by a committee that
could do something with it. Does the Water Conservancy still do
like community partnerships? Would they partner with us?
Yes, and you know what else? Most of the developers, I've talked to them about
this, they would help pitch in the money to make some of these things happen.
Um, yes, and it could be like— they used to have that garden down in
Orem where people could walk through and see it. We could do something
like that here.
We also need to consider just the maintenance of drip lines.
Like, you got to make it a big enough park. Maybe it's adjacent to
Quarry Ride or whatever parks. Somewhere where there's water. Yeah,
there's water and you're You're gonna get a parks tech that's not gonna have
to remember all of these disparate gardens throughout the city. Maybe we
should just form an official task group or
something. Yeah, committee.
Someone who wants to research this and come up with a plan, that sounds like
a good idea. Is anyone interested in doing that and want to take
that on as a side project? I'd be happy to help.
Awesome. I can work with you on it. I would love to.
Okay, and I'm available. Just so you guys know, I've been
asking for fruit trees in our parks for like 12 years,
and Brad Hickman has said no to me for years. When that fruit drops,
if nobody's picking it, it makes a huge mess. You know what else makes
messes? Scorpions. Bulls.
Like, put it in a place where we don't care.
Okay, let's, uh, Circle back. Yes, get back to the mental health
section to identify 3 there that we're already doing.
Well, mental health is a gardening thing. Why is it on there? Yes,
so we do have all of these things already. We have the,
like, the naloxone access.
We already have naloxone. We already have the disposal service
and the free gun locks at the library. We do. Oh really? We need
more Advertisement of that?
Yes. I had no idea until I read the— I
had to ask, I had to ask Soraya because I'm in the other building.
Hey, do we have this? I feel like we have one. Yeah, she came out
and she's like, yeah, there's one. So the medication drop box is right over here.
Where are sheriffs and reporters down the hall? I've got
a bag sitting in my garage that's been there
for years. Her first question was, do you want me to post about
that? I said, hold off until we talk about it at least here. And then,
yeah, I think we want to post about it. I think it'd be good to
make a post calling it Bring Mine.
Throw some of that in the comments and say, as it fits into your town
schedule, throw some of that dog stuff in. It's like a grocery bag
full of dog poop. We're at a community cleanup. We're also going to partner with
the DEA. To have a prescription drop-off. Can we have a gun
buyback too? Yeah, people will stand there and
buy them. Zach and I will take care of it. So yeah,
we'll have a prescription— we're working to get it squared away, but they can
bring used prescriptions and drop off just at the dumpsters in
the bin that they provide, and then it will be hauled away by the DEA
and stuff like that. Nice. So just to provide another— I feel like something that
They're like very— there's
a ton of advertisement about that kind of thing, and they have like a medicine
drop day and all these things, and we should definitely— Yes,
there's also the host recurring community event
that promotes social connection.
We've already got your lunches for the elderly there,
and then there was one where the suicide prevention walk works. Did you
ever get a hold of Abby? She didn't respond. Okay. But I do think—
This is the one at Cedar Valley? Yeah. Yeah. I would love— I really think
that it will work fine to partner. I just— she
probably is like, I don't know who you are or why you're contacting me,
and she's probably also on Summer's break. Well, that's fair. I gave
her both the names. But do you know about the suicide—
it's a walk that Cedar Valley does every year is a walk to prevent suicide.
However, they— you can come in and put who you're walking
for, and they have booths there from resources
for mental health. So, it's a really great event, and I'm sure they would love
to get it out in the community. Yeah, it's at the high school.
Yeah, it's at the high school. But we do already have 3 things
there, so we have— of that.
And we are now officially a Believer City. Yeah, so you actually
have plenty of them there. Yes, that's true.
Or put it as one of your 3 expansions. The Believer
Mile? What was it? It was Motivational Mile, but what's it going to be called
next year? Motivational Mile. Okay. Yeah, that's a
good one. We're also doing partnering with Craig Whiting to do
the half marathon. So whatever happened with the city
that he was competing against? What did they have to do if he made
it? No, no, no, the— what's this? He wasn't really competing against them.
They were just calling him out from California or somewhere. Well,
he had to do something if he didn't get it. What did
they have to do if he did? I don't
know. He had to go run his flag in their city if he didn't
make it this year. But it seems like there was something that they had to
do if he did get it.
Okay, so I have— we just
choose which ones, but we have— we do senior lunches and senior bingo and
other activities. We have naloxone
kits that we offer. Gun locks. Gun Locks,
Narc-X Kiosk, which is the medication
drop-off, the Believer City, Show Me a Sign organization,
Motivational Mile. Pick the coolest ones because they make a video
about us and show it during ULCT. So for sure we should do Believer
City because we want to show that off. Nobody else is. So pick the ones
that like are totes bragging rights. Totes. Totes.
And I think like senior— the senior lunch, you could
get footage of the senior luncheon.
And then they could do a video of Smith Ranch Park.
Yeah, so they'll do— they'll interview the mayor probably,
and then they'll interview certain other people as part of the
video. Oh my gosh. And then your additional 3
you needed are So
we need— let's see, we need
a health plan.
So the community
health plan is a 3-year
You guys
may as well share it with the whole— Oh, I drew on
you. You're totally fine. We're just working on something with the Jazz right now.
They're gonna do something on hopefully August 30th.
Uh, they're gonna bring out some of their players and just do a free little
clinic or something. That's fun. But I mean, you can You should totally pair that
with a little youth belonging mental health thing
at the same time. It takes 5, 10 minutes.
Promote, you know, why that's important for
them. That's so easy. They're already gathered and excited
about some jazz guy there. Why not throw in somebody talking about mental health?
If you have your— my contact info,
we'll create a card for you.
So what we have to do is a 3-year community—
let's see, community health plan. And health plan
looks at data to understand the health needs of your community and choosing additional health
strategies to implement over a 3-year period. So it's— as
a large community, we have to implement 3 additional strategies every 3 years,
so just 3 total for the next 3 years. Let's add
1,000 miles of trail in our city in 3
years. Remember how I told you it took me 9 years to get
Smith Ranch to art? He's an artist at heart. I'm used to being
loud and a mess, but Jay knows how to do stuff. If we know we're
gonna pair with the high school anyway, the destigmatize
mental illness through community campaign or event, the community can do that
campaign in conjunction with supporting the high school's
event. I have something I would like to bring up about this
stuff too that specifically goes with the mental health, but I
would want to know if there is interest in this, but there's the Communities
That Care Coalition and that we
could join that. And this— oh, is this
the an animal? No, no, no. We used to have this,
and I don't know why it stopped. It's because the lady,
Karen, I believe was her name, she left,
so she was no longer with them. And so it kind of— I thought we
already had one. I think the city is so— yeah, I got so many cases
of spatulas from them. But it was done through more like— they always have like
family eat at home. That way. Yeah, I have a contact With
the person who's over it.
And I think— and I was kind of— I lived in Pleasant Grove when they
started it there too, um, so I was a little bit a part of that.
Anyways, I just think that it would be— I think there's a huge gap in
our city for resources for mental health, and we have a lot of
issues. And I think that's something— Yes, we do. It would be really cool to—
Did you drop your favorite one?
So what is that? Is that bringing
it to City Council and City Council gets— do we create like a work session
for it just like we had the cat code people last night?
Or— Well, that's a good one, Charlotte. No, I was there. Oh,
okay. Anyway, is that
what we need to do if it's something we want to consider doing? Because like
the City Council would have to You're talking about Communities That Care specifically,
or you're talking about creating a new— Communities That Care.
And you're right, we used to do that because Ben— other Ben Reeves that used
to be on the city council was part of that. Well, do you remember they
would ask the city council to do like the Eat at Home with
Your Family week, like family dinner night? And there was like the tacos and pizza,
and they passed out spatulas to everyone. I mean, they used to be
super into all of our events. Yes, and that's why I'm like, we need to
get whoever's doing that again because that was good.
But so I don't know if it needs to go to City Council because we
already were that community. I don't know if it has a budget item. Like,
you will have to hire someone though.
We shared someone when it was there.
But didn't we share someone with Saratoga Springs? Yes. Yes.
Yeah. And do they still have someone or no? I think Saratoga
Springs. We probably are cool enough to have our own. Yeah. So,
uh, I think I attended a couple of meetings for that. And maybe it
falls under the same thing that we have, like, you know, our RAD kids people
and like that. Maybe it's because we budget,
like, I think it's like $10,000 a year for hours for them. Maybe we
do something like that for a part-timer communities that care. So is
the recommendation from Community Services Board to City Council
to consider budgeting for something like that? I'm just trying to figure
out what the process is to make this happen. It would be— I would have
to come up with a presentation and give it to you guys.
I don't even know if you'd need to do that. How do we figure out—
how do we figure out— right, but how do we figure out when that was
and if something needs taken— like if we need to take action?
I feel like— I think a presentation is fine. I can— I
will reach out to Owen at Saratoga Springs because they—
he worked over that for them and find out what did
they have to do as the city to be involved in that. And because
did we just contribute some money toward it? Or, I mean, it would be good
to know how Eagle Mountain facilitated that before too.
So Because as of now, like, to bring it here now, it would
be just the coordinators, all of it the city would have to hire, and then
the county provides most everything for it. They provide the classes and everything
that's needed. Um, but sorry,
that's just something I think that we could do over the next 3 years.
That's a pretty easy one. It's a good one too. It'll have a
huge return on investment. We'll see good things from it. It was good before.
Whether that's implementing or partnering with the communities that care organization.
But I don't know, I mean, that's gonna— I would imagine
that'll take 3 years to get set up, but just based on how
things tend to work. So,
C's gonna check into it. Is Jesse gonna still plan on coming in
and doing a little quick work session presentation on it?
Because I think you have a It was a different perspective too because they had
the suicide focus, and I don't know that Communities That Care did
a ton of that with us. There was more about family members. It's all about
prevention is what the Communities That Care is about, so you can choose
from like, like there's like a few different
things, and it's all about the risk factors and preventing
addiction or abuse or suicide. And all things
like that. So it just would depend on what we want to focus on.
We need 3 goals. So we could do Join the Communities That Care Coalition
as one. Do a destigmatize
mental illness through a community campaign or event and partner,
like do a community-wide campaign
leading up to the suicide prevention event. prevention walk at the
school as a second one. Do we want to focus all of them on
mental health? That's what I was going to ask. Does it say if it has
to be one in each area, just 3 at any—
Let me look at the actual form. I'm pretty sure it's just any 3,
but— And it has to be something new that we aren't already
doing? Like, could we say, oh, we're going to do the Motivational Mile
in connection wants to leave our city. It has to be something
new. Another thing, while I look
at that, someone did reach out to us at the farmers market and brought up
that they want to bring out a type of Special Olympics or bring—
I don't remember exactly what she said. We had a team because my girls were
on it. Oh really? Brady Bears, yeah. And Chelsea Brown
and her husband, I can't remember what her husband's name is, they were the coaches
for it. I was just looking at— because they were bocce ball silver
medal champions at state. So bocce ball is
really easy for us to put in and do adaptive. That's an
easy adaptive sport. So we don't have anything right
now, do we? Lehigh has a huge Special Olympics team. Like,
they do a ton there. Jason's been very interested in implementing
that. Let's do it. That's a great idea. Let's do that as our next one.
as well. So what is it?
Implement a Special Olympics adaptive sports.
I would do slash adaptive sports because maybe we don't do the Olympic side of
it, but we still have— Just adaptive sports program is a great place
to start with the aspiration for Special Olympics.
It is the coolest thing in the world. Yeah, and they have teams that are
part Special Olympics people and part I don't want to
say regular people, but, you know, like they're mixed teams, and that's
really, really neat too. Yeah. Are you talking about Unified
Sports? It's— there's different heats in the bocce
ball competition, and they had ones that were all people that were
special athletes and then ones that weren't, and they had mixed teams.
Because there's Unified Sports that does that. You pair regular
students with their life Jason, you know
the people who started Eagle Mountain Rec Sports? Their kids were a
part of that Special Olympics team with my kids. Oh, they were? Yeah, so like
maybe they would help with something. So I know we decided—
we've talked about the Communities That Care, and then that— I don't know,
is there a different one that we want to do rather than destigmatize,
other than the community campaign for mental health? Is there something else we want
to do that gardens as community gardens as the
third option instead. So basically one from each?
Yeah, if you guys think that Brad can't say
no, don't tell him I said that.
But that's another thing is do we want to say that we're going to do
that before we even get the research and all that stuff done, or do we
want something— That's the only reason I didn't suggest that one is because we said
we were going to look into it, which means that We don't want to commit
to it yet. Yeah. So it can be a little— we can do the
other ones I mentioned, maybe as possibilities.
Add wayfinding signage for trails that provide both time and distance for routes.
Develop a new walking/biking trail or add to an existing one.
That could be in the bike park. I mean, we just got a grant for
that. So yeah, yeah, that trail over there.
Messaging campaigns for certain I
think that you could do a lot with existing trails,
even to have guides for where we have the
trails classified for different categories of fitness or
ability, where it makes it easy for a family that might have even like
babies in strollers or kids in wheelchairs,
or you know what I'm saying? And advertising. And advertising,
yes. So that— and they're grouped together so it's easy for
people to find activities that fit their
family or their special circumstances. We have a lot of that stuff, but I like—
I don't know how to get to the trailhead to go up to the flats.
Right. You know, or, you know, people like to do that for a friend the
other day. Yeah, people like to hike Turtle Hill, but some people
don't know what Turtle Hill is. So if we were to make a specific campaign
for healthy living to let people know where are our trails,
how do they find them, and then,
you know, have the wayfinding signs there. That can all
work together for that goal. Would that include—
could we add like mile markers to the trails?
I think that's really helpful. Yeah, good idea.
Love it. We just have to have starting Starting points for a trail and
an ending point. And then, yeah. And so
is the question— is the suggestion to do that on the off— like the
dirt trails, or to do it on the paved trails as well? I think,
I think, personally, start with the most used
ones. And then we have that data. Start with the most used and then spread
from there. Did I say 1,000 miles?
Yes. Okay. Can we start? Can we start with Sage Valley Airport
Road? Our average— I'll follow up
with you on that one. He's gonna change to 1,000 feet. Can it be 5
o'clock? I almost got hit twice. I would walk 5
o'clock. We're averaging 1,800 feet of
linear path a year. We did 3,000 feet last year,
550 feet— Great. Or no, last year was 550 feet.
Years ago it was 3,000 feet. So if I average that out, it's almost a
mile. Okay. There's new paved trails every year. New paved trail in
3 years. Now figure out how long it takes me and you to pave a
mile. Dude, I bet you Mayor could do it faster
than you guys. As long as somebody's helping us out. One hand, you never know.
I don't have to drive the dump truck. All right, so do we have all
the 3 that we want to Yes,
I've got join the Communities That Care Coalition,
which focuses on suicide prevention and
other— implement adaptive sports programs.
And then wayfinding signage slash physical activity campaign
that implements signage for trails, with time and distance and
a campaign to get people out. I mean, we're— if we're going to do the
work for the off-site trails, I mean, off-road trails plan, we ought
to have a campaign letting people know they're there. Yes. Okay.
I think that's awesome. Yeah, I was gonna say that a lot of the trails
we have are on private property too. Yeah, but if we mark the
ones that aren't, yeah, and delineate
These are ones that you can be out on, right? Yes. My goal is
to get all of those, at least up in the Hidden Valley area, shut down.
Legal. Yeah. Legalize. Come on, Steve.
So then we can have results. If he didn't have 4 jobs to do,
maybe he could stay here. Okay, is there anything else that
we need to discuss tonight with the communities that— or sorry, the health Yeah,
do you have everything you need to do that? I think that is— let me
just look real quick. The only other thing was the letter
that we send, the letter of commitment to identify
some key achievements. The ones I suggested,
they had like just 3 bullets, you can do more. Wasn't that
bad. I suggested the off-street trails master plan,
Sports sponsorships to make programs more accessible to
families. And the Believer City and
community food pantry. Is there anything else that
was big that you think— We were saying that Mascot Miracles,
our sick horse rodeo, was a new city event this year that we kind
of brought under our wing. And I think that's a cool adaptive activity.
That's a neat one. And that's one that now the Pony
Express Events does? Yes, well, it's done it, but now that— yeah,
but it's like, now that it's officially Pony Express Days related
again and the city's helping. I think that's a cool— plus
that's something that no one else does. There's no one else in the state that
does that. So if they make a video about us, remember,
it's all about goals. And they
do a stick horse rodeo? It's Pony Express events, and Eagle Mountain City does
a stick horse rodeo for Mascot Miracles.
Mayor would have more details for you, but that's— I'm sure.
Yeah. Okay, is that all we need
then for now? And then we could just keep working on these
things. Jay, you said you're gonna look into the gardens soon? Yep.
Okay, awesome. And I will
work on the community center stuff.
Okay, well, awesome. Then I think we can move on to the next topic,
which is the American 250 and Eagle Mountain 30. We don't need
a motion for any of that, do we? Are we just— that can all just
be— do we need to? I think they're just doing action items. We're not spending
any money on it. No, I think they're just action items. Yeah, these are just
discussions, right? Yeah. I think the ones that you really have to vote on are
ones that you're— there's going to be a financial impact, right? I think
we can just state that it was the will of the
body to do this. Move forward with those. Okay.
All right. So now we have the America 250, UNO 30,
plans and events. Okay, I had a little thing, but it
deleted apparently. So here's,
here's from my memory,
the events coming up for America 250, Eagle Mountain 30.
In July, we have the laser show and
summer bash, which we have these cool stickers for.
Thank you. And then, and that's
This Saturday, Saturday night. And then in
August, my proposal is to do
Walk 30, which is similar to America 250— or
Walk 250 as part of America 250.
But much easier. So either— we talked about this
a little bit before, but Either we make it just like that one
and say you walk, run, bike, hike, whatever, 30 miles,
and then you turn that in and you get the sticker for it or something.
You could call it Move 30 instead of Walk 30. Move 30?
Does that mean we could do Prancercise? Oh my gosh,
yes! Have you seen the video for that?
Yes, I love it. Except for you have to video it. Can I veto
any of this?
Just make a motion and say Steve has to do it. Yeah, do it.
Get the video of Steve. So for
my Walk 30, um,
so either we do 30 miles during the
month of August, or you just make
it more accessible for everyone and more fun and you just say 30
any time. Let's do 30 anything, so involving recreation or
walking or hiking or biking. So, you know, you walk with 30
ladies, get together and they go walking, or you and
your friends are walking 30 dogs all across the city. 30 cowboys. I want to
see a video of that. I think we should ask
them to submit videos because I think it would be pretty cool. Yes, I think
I would love that. I think that that would be really cool. It would be
really fun to request submissions for how they did
it. And then we can give out special wristbands and sweatbands
to the people who complete it. Steve goes home very tired from
this meeting. We're like hurting cats. I mean— When I'm
in charge of the meeting, I'm super good and stay on track. When I'm not—
We do need like a prize for it, but if it's not very hard to
do, then the prize shouldn't be amazing. I think we should do it for
the most original Walk 30. Then how would
you judge that though? It's subjective. Very. But I'm saying,
who would judge that? The board. We watch all the
videos. Maybe. The one we
laugh hardest at. We can have a laugh meter.
I think, um, you could do a drawing. So we can have a, we can
have a sticker, the special one for Anyone who completes the
program and they can come pick it up here or something like that. You could
ask Anytime Fitness if they would be willing to donate a 1-year
membership and advertise that along with the Eagle Mountain 30
because that's some publicity for them, but it's a huge
donation that they give and that would be a cool thing to— If you don't
want to have to choose, you could do it as a drawing. Submit your— submit
a way of donating. They all go into a drawing for a 1-year membership.
I like that idea. That would be huge advertising. A drawing?
Everyone who completes it, their name goes into a drawing? Oh yeah.
You just submit, you know, a picture or whatever we say of
what they did and it goes into a
drawing. Yeah. So I can talk to communications
and And we could have either a simple form
they fill out, like a JotForm kind of thing on the website. It's like,
hey, I completed this.
And there's a link to that in the social media posts or the
QR code or something. And then they can—
maybe they can submit a video or submit a picture or something with that.
Okay. I was trying to think of how can we get people to post this?
And have everyone be able to see. You should post it
with a tag, a hashtag. Yeah, but if they're a private account, it doesn't
matter. No one's gonna see it. They could just reply within the
post. Oh yeah, have them, have them attach it to the social media post.
It's our post. Yeah, it goes out. Say put it in the comments. And then
you get more views for every time someone— Yeah, it bumps it.
And if people see that other people are doing it, they're more likely to do
it. Because everybody's doing it.
And tag your friends. Melissa for sure will do it because
it'll be everybody doing it.
And then I'll get mocked on Facebook. And I'll cry. And then
I'll go get a sugar soda.
I know the more things that go on social media, the It
doesn't matter, it's good. There are people that are homebound
that this is like their one chance to connect with other people in the community.
So like, for them alone, I'm willing to do something fun.
Plus you could have like the mayor do 30 roping or
like something really— You could wear your eagle costume. Oh my gosh, I'll totally do
it in my eagle costume. You didn't have
to even ask me. Hey, I wonder if we could find enough people
that have— 30 people that have those dinosaur costumes. Or 30 eagle costumes,
because I know there's like 3 people. Now you have to actually do something like
walking, running, moving. All right,
dinosaurs and go walking. Animal costumes, walk dinosaurs.
2.5-mile or 5-mile walk in Cedar Pass Ranch. Okay, we picked
up our kids from the school bus. Well, I mean, you're away from traffic.
I mean, this isn't saying it has to be there,
but we can close off Crossroads Boulevard and do something there
too. For anyone willing to participate, we may throw together something like that.
Let's get it in the video and post it. I think videos are fun.
We did that during 2020, and we have videos of all the council members and
like different staff members like during 2020,
during COVID It was cool. Like, it was fun. Doing certain
things. Mayor Gus Morlan and his His wife did exercising, and I read
a book, a children's book.
Activities and things for connection.
Okay, so are you supportive of the Walk 30? Yes,
yes. In August? Wholeheartedly. August is a good time
because it's still summer, still nice outside for
the most part, except for
flooding and rain. How much else is happening at the city in August as far
as events? I think that's great. That's great. Okay. There's a little room over there,
Don. If you want attention, just raise your hand. Let's see.
September, there's a bunch in September. So there's Charlotte's—
the high school's Constitution pop-up museum.
There's a pop-up as well as the boot camp. The Constitution
boot camp. And then there
is— I think that's the end. There's the Day of Service. The 9/11
Day of Service. Shop Fest and Prep Fest. Shop Fest, Prep Fest, and the
dumpsters. No, it matters. What's the last one that
you said? Are you still doing the backpacks? So that was
my other thing in September that we talked about.
Um, and so here's the backpack.
Nice! Reply with yours. That's cool. They look like that.
They're like a hiking backpack, sort of, you know. You should do
a video showing the backpack and what's in it. Yes. We'll get some B-roll
after we pass the taxi. It's just groundwork. I don't know.
Everyone's gonna be like, oh, Citi's wasting money on a backpack.
Okay, here's what I have so far on the inside. Get ready, you guys.
Okay, so we've got We've got this water bottle. It's got the logo.
We were like a little disappointed in the water bottle, right, Dawn? Because it's kind
of light and flimsy. Don't worry,
we'll get it right for the 60th birthday. No, I'm just kidding.
We've got a hat. That one's cool. That one's
not like that weird V hat. 30th anniversary hat.
There's these, uh, Stormtrooper hat. Oh yeah, America 250.
The America 250 fanny pack.
There's a t-shirt.
Eagle Mountain sunglasses. There's several—
we have several colors we can put in there.
And then we've got— We should get the library to put a book in
there. See, we should get the library to put a book in
there and then put something in there that's like a sticker on it with the
library. It's what? Just a book, any book.
Like, let them pick it. Atomic Habits.
Maybe something like that. Yeah, that's a good book. It's an excellent book. What?
Atomic Habits. And put a library, uh, yeah, and say
come and get your library card at the Eaglemont Library. Like, let's use it
as a way to shout out to them. There's a pin, a lapel
pin, and a keychain. That's cool. It's the logo.
And there's a sticker
because we had a bunch of extra, so we've got a bunch— 30 stickers.
That, that's one of the items. Oh my God, are you
kidding me? And we've got a pickleball Paddle that's American.
I mean, that's gonna sell everyone one. Isn't that cool? Oh, forget the book.
That's good. And then we can
put— I just threw these in, but we can do like, uh,
pickleballs, a couple pickleballs or something. I love it.
If we order teeny tiny little UV stickers, we get the brand pickleballs.
Like Ninja Turtles. They're tiny.
I like the book idea. We could do something like that with a light.
It's lame, just forget it. Nobody likes salad
soup. There's 30 backpacks. We could put in little black
light pen lights that they can use for the scorpion.
Yeah, and then you could do it on a cardstock, cut slits in it,
slide that in there, and then put a QR code to the Wildlife Alliance.
There you go. You really could. Don't get too crazy on me, but we,
we have time. We've got a month or so to— the Chamber wants to— I'll
put something in. I don't think the little title is gonna be big enough.
What? We can put something in. We have really cool fidget spinners.
So something from the Chamber? The Wildlife Alliance
should do something. I'll talk to them and see. I think the Arts Alliance should
do something. Like all of the partnering organizations.
The Arts Alliance would put your book in there for you. Yeah,
we know someone. I know a girl.
Anything else that's missing that you think,
like, people will want? I think
it's really great. And just the fun of a scavenger hunt.
Do we still have printed maps that we do every year? I don't think
so. I thought they were up at customer service. Could we do— could
we— just asking— could we do like with her binoculars?
Depends how much it costs, yeah. There's a
small, like a mini binoculars? Declaration of Independence reading. Well,
I'm thinking for the wildlife. How many are you doing?
30? That's a good idea
though, little mini binoculars or something.
Look for wildlife. Yeah, you can find like a cute little
dollar bird watching book too. Like, there— I have actually
found some little, uh, guides that are not very expensive
that we could probably furnish. I'll check this in my board. Because you're partnering
with organizations, then it doesn't become like super commercial. It's just,
yeah, here's some entities that help support the activities in Eagle Mountain,
because I wouldn't do every one, but just little things. So we need
a Community Service Board sticker in there is what you're saying?
We do. Then we were going to create a sticker
for the treasure hunt as well. And everyone who arrives— only one person
gets the backpack, unfortunately, at each site— but
everyone who arrives gets a shirt and a sticker if they arrive within
a certain amount of time. So then the question really is,
and we've talked about it a little A little bit, but I don't know that
we've fully settled. I think the options are— we talked
about maybe doing it in September. You could do— here are my
options, okay? Don't react yet until all the options come out.
You can do— Sounds like me talking to my wife. Right?
Don't even roll your eyes or make a face yet.
You can do One backpack
a day for 30 days. So one treasure hunt
every day. I like that. Someone on the board's going to
be in charge of that. I was going to say, that's just a lot of
waiting for people to ask. Anyway, I'll tell you all the options, and then there's
obviously pros and cons to each of these. But, um, we can do
every Wednesday, either every 2 Tuesday or
every Wednesday night, because there's 5 of those in September. You could do 6
treasure hunts on each of those days.
You can do it all on one day, all 30
on the same day. Jeez. Or you could do— you'd space
it out and do 10 on 3 different days,
right? You do a whole weekend, you do a Thursday, Friday, Saturday, and do 10
each day on those days. Something like that.
But of course, pros and cons are things like we want— we don't
want the excitement to die off.
Oh, it's not gonna die off. People are gonna be so excited.
People do that one for like the little treasure chest. Yeah.
And they post about it all over the state of Utah. Like, it's a big
deal. But that's a lot of money. Listen, their prizes were
dolls. But they're an open door. They can also come to all the events
and get the exact same prizes. Easy, pal. Not easy. We don't
want the excitement to die off, and then we also don't want tons of
work for everyone who's involved in it. Are you
wanting to do like a different treasure hunt
or just run the same program if you did it over 3 weekends?
So the— I think the idea,
and I'd have to get with communications and go through it in detail,
but I have a whole map that shows possible locations.
I can send that to you if you guys want to see it, because it
won't pull up. But I had— I tried to get locations
that are, that are public if possible. There are some
that aren't, and we have to talk to the landowner. But scattered
throughout the city. So at a park,
so Cordy Wright Park, Smith Ranch Park, Brandon Park,
Valley View Park, kind of spread out. Some places
that are hard to get to, but like hiking or biking, so Prayer Flag Hill,
maybe Turtle Hill, or I
think Firefly at the water tank at the top of their, their trail.
Maybe the Firefly Park as well with the skate park and stuff.
Maybe we do them at the high school and the middle schools.
And you'll have 30 different treasure hunts. So I— yeah,
okay, which is hard. And then the other part is that I have— I
was trying to think through is we'd probably have them
at the same time. every day when we do these,
right? In the evening because the kids are home from
school. Um, I think just throw it into
AI and say we need 30 destinations in Eagle Mountain
and we need 4 clues for each one. It'll give it to you in like
12 seconds. So we need clues and maybe we have a picture that's taken that
shows— it's like a view from there or something that would
give a clue. And then the other— I think I think most of all you
need would be a picture. Yeah, that's all I need. I'd be able to figure
it out. Just one picture of either of the place or— Yeah, because people do
those little Christmas ornament pickups and stuff. Yeah, exactly. We used to do carnival tickets.
That's how we did it. We did giveaways and we would just go place it
random and just take a picture of it, like a close-up, so you can't tell
where it's at unless you bring in a RV. I will say, based off my
experience from that, please do not forget a drop location in White Hills.
You will be hung. We've got fireflies. I would go—
that would make it worse if you did a firefly into their parks.
Go Old White Hills. Like, they are very excluded. They're like
annexed from the city, and so they'll freaking love it. There's a park
there. Where do you live? It's a good
idea. Oh, I was looking at that, and she's right.
And so then there's a— there would be a certain time,
and then anyone who arrives within a certain number of minutes at
that time gets to— Why don't you just do like the first 10 people that
show up? Or yeah, okay, the first 10. I would just say like don't make
people sit there forever. That's going to be too much work. Like The Amazing Race.
Yeah. Sorry. So do you send the hint and then
the first 10 people that arrive after you send the hint? Yeah. And then
the next day say we're going to give our hint at 5 PM on
this day, then everybody comes to the city's channel and watches for it.
Maybe we need a little flag that says, you know,
this treasure's been claimed, and you just leave it there so that if
they find it, they know that they made it there, but that the prizes have
been given away. Well, if they find out— oh, I guess that's
true. You can post that it was found. You could do both.
But we should make them pose for a picture and And like say, look,
they found it. It's always 2 or 3 days. So we have to have someone
there at each site, I think. Of course. And then you either
have the bag there as, you know, you take a picture of
the bag in the spot. And the problem, the only problem that I can see
is if we're at a park and there are kids and people playing at the
park and we come in with our bag. Well, we have to be a little
bit more selective. Gotta be secretive and selective,
but A little more out of the way. Well, it just
depends on the time of day for some parks
too, right? Right. Okay.
So what are you doing? Anyway. Every day on the weekends? Oh yeah,
what do you want to do? Every day would be hard for
your staff. Very hard. What if it was— well. What time does
the sun go down in August? September. September. Or September.
6:38. For real? Yeah, I looked it
up earlier. Okay. She knows. I'm like
Rain Man over here. I know, that's what I'm thinking.
She has the sunset table memory.
I mean, like Saturday mornings to avoid kids running around.
Yeah, what if you did like a Wednesday evening, Saturday morning,
so you hit one during the weekday and one on the weekend?
That sounds good to me. Me too.
And then you just do multiple on the same night and post all the pictures.
It's 7:12.
You're doing multiple at the same time, so you just post the pictures of all
of them and they just pick one? Might be a sale on this time.
Whatever's closest to them. Oh my gosh. Because then you can get a lot of
people going in at the same time. They'll figure it out. I think
it's gonna fail in the Senate. Oh my gosh. Yeah,
there's like a 30% chance of it passing, so. Oh wow.
Uh, I don't know, whenever the Senate gets around to doing anything.
Oh man. So Wednesday evening Saturday mornings.
Yes. And what did you just say? Definitely. Should it be Saturday
afternoons though because of the farmers market and stuff like that? Or is it fine?
Does it not matter? We can do it in one of the farmers markets.
Is there a ton of soccer games on Saturday mornings? Like when do most
of our soccer teams play soccer? Tips on what time? Most start on
the 15th of August. Time of day? In the morning. So maybe it
should be Saturday morning. Because I think that's gonna expand It won't be in the
afternoon. Decent-sized pocket. Well, then they do the Wednesday evenings. Those are like early.
That's true. But good catch.
So we're talking maybe afternoon? Yeah. Well,
it all comes down to when we can staff it, Steve. I think the board's
saying we love the idea. But we get that
there's logistics of staffing. I'll figure out the logistics.
And then when we get this going, any of you of course are
invited to participate and help if you want. Oh my gosh, you couldn't keep
me away. You have to be standing
by the stage. So you're saying there's not an asterisk of our family members can't
participate? You don't get to collect the bag, you have to pack the bag.
No, I anticipate, yeah, you can't— I'll stand right there on the little square that
says you've been eliminated and tell the people who come late. You should make
sure that they do post that city staff and their families are
not eligible. Right. Yeah, that's, that's it. Including elected officials.
Yes. Are we city staff? No, isn't that the worst? No, you're volunteers.
But if you guys know where the locations are, I know I've been to our
economic development golf tournament and man, they give away amazing prizes because we get
sponsors. It's because they don't raise money for any good cause. They just take thousands
of dollars in. For nothing to go buy prizes.
Okay, um, should be something we discuss. Yeah. Okay.
Oh, okay. And then the only other thing was in
October we have the Halloween Town, which will have a fun
ghost sticker for that. And, um, and I feel
like there was one other thing in October. There's the adaptive Halloween,
adaptive trick-or-treat, a movie in the park, and that's when our half marathon
will be, is October. October 3rd is the half marathon. Yeah, October 3rd.
Yeah, October 3rd. Yeah, awesome. Okay, and then—
So what you're saying is it's not gonna slow down? It's not slowing down.
November Turkey Trot and, uh, something else. The Veterans Breakfast,
which will play a role in that.
There's something else too. Village for the
veterans breakfast. Yeah, please share. Well,
it's a city event now instead of—
so, okay, go on. It's just one of the community service things.
So what do you need to help with? Um, I don't know because this is
the first time hearing that it's actually a city event now. So we took it
away last year. Remember how ridiculous it was that every single time they do
it, they're like, oh, we don't have Yeah, juice. Okay, we'll run to
Macy's and buy a bunch of juice. So am I— is my staff taking the
whole event over? I think you guys should. That's what I told Rudy was gonna
happen. I was like, let's actually get what happened, so let's verify. Yeah, I'm like,
I just need— well, we're supposed to sit down with you, whatever. We're supposed to
sit down with you to talk about all the events because there's one— ones in
their MOU that they propose that they want to help do something
for. So like, let's talk about that offline or I'm happy to do whatever.
But even for everything that's coming up, like Friday, Saturday,
whatever day? Um, Saturday is
busy. It's gonna be very busy, especially with the fireworks come. The fireworks
show, we had 20,000 people. I'm anticipating the same attendance.
So anyone who wants to come and help, we have like a watermelon
eating contest. We need help with like judging and getting that going.
and all the age groups.
The Arts Alliance is handing out glow sticks for us.
We always need help keeping kids back on the stage, like when Trash Panda's
up and stuff like that. So if you guys just want to come, and if
you're looking for something to do rather than just enjoy the event, come over to
my booth. We'll put you to work. We'll give you fun tasks. It's fun.
It's a party. It's a great time. This is one of my favorite events,
so if you haven't already, come. Awesome. experienced it. She told me, she told me
the other day it was her favorite. Yeah, I— well, I have a hard time
saying Silent Santa is not my actual favorite event, so— but this
event is super fun. We can always use help. Um,
there's that one. And then after that we have—
I don't know,
Saturday, back to school nights. Um,
That event, we have all of the elementary schools coming to set up a
booth with their principals and crossing guards.
We did it last year. We did one in 2019
too, but it was on August 1st.
Oh no, but we did a back-to-school safety fair with
Be Ready Eagle Mountain. Yeah, so,
but it's, it's the first time that it's coming events.
What's the name of the August 1st one? Back to School Night.
So we have a clothing swap. We're collecting clothing donations and back-to-school items.
Um, people come and take what they need, drop off what they
want to share. Um, that's a good event. I think that would
be a good event for the board to set up a booth at and just
give information to the community and collect information. If you're looking for a place to
do that, that would be a good family phone night to do that type
of stuff. Well, then for sure, that's August 1st. August 1st.
Then we need to hustle on a banner. Yeah, like,
can we get that information to comms? Remember how she asked to design a banner?
We— if it's— if we want to do a booth by August 1st, we first—
we should try to have it ready. If we're sitting there as a community services
board, we should be able to identify ourselves. That— otherwise it
doesn't— even like soft So when you guys go to Shop Fest— or not Shop
Fest, that too, but yeah, the farmers market. Yes.
So, um, yeah, I don't
know, there's just lots of things. Let me put together all like our calendar,
calendar of events for the rest of the year. I'll send you an email with
potential items that we need help with, what you guys can do at the events.
I'll send it to you and you can disperse it. That would be awesome.
Thank you. Is there anything else on the events or
anything? Nope, thank you very much. Okay, um, we wanted
to really keep this to 2 hours tonight.
Um, did you guys all look over the email about the wrap tax
stuff? Has anyone had any, like,
great ideas about anything? So just one
of them, uh, just As I'm sitting here researching
and listening, the community garden thing could be brought
under the RAP tax. That's— it can be funded by that.
Not for— apparently not for like continuing— The
building of it could. Yeah, but the one-time purchase, like building the
actual garden could be part of it. And putting in the sprinkler line.
Yeah, yeah. Running the water. thing. Yeah. Now,
would that come— if we were to do that under the RAP tax, would that
be something that came like as— it would have to—
assuming we get a criteria down with an application, would we have to submit that
as an application and then review it? Like, how would that be? That would be
a city— that would be a city-run application. Yeah, how would that—
We need either a separate group to submit it or have the
city submit it as a project. Part of
it, submit it as a part. I'm not sure. I gotta talk
with Ben about how we want to do applications from the city. I was thinking
about how Lehigh has it. Yeah, because Lehigh says 70% of
their RAP funds go toward council and city designated
projects and 30% are grant things.
But I would think that the Community Services Board could help do.
And we all— the City Council ultimately would have to decide the 30/70
split or whatever that is. But the thing about that— I would actually rather not
have a percentage. Well, yeah, because— well, we— Charlotte and I were talking about
this, but like, um, say someone
comes in wanting grant funding for a frisbee golf course,
disc golf course, that is technically like— I
feel like that can't— I don't feel like 30%
for community grants. I don't know, that seems like it'd be more like a parks
thing that it would have to be in. Well, sorry, Lehigh does
cultural arts, right, community type things,
gets the 30%. And if it's a park, that's why there's so
much in the 70% side. Because I
think the thing is, is if it's a park, the city has to
approve it. If it's a play or an orchestra concert,
then it doesn't really matter. It's one and done. Which totally makes sense. So the
ways that I was looking at how different cities do this, there's— you
can split it into, yeah, city, like from city-run things and
community things, and then also from like Parks and Rec.
And there's also 501 requests. Yeah, so I mean
I don't know, soon we're going to have to start nailing down, we've got to
be able to vet however we're going to do this really well to make sure
it's solid. So we really need to— Well, and I think the
example with the very eager disc golf guy is you
will— I just know from the match grant, it can go really, really ugly
really, really quickly unless we're very communicative and
help people understand how to apply for it. a lot of things that can
go wrong. Yeah, so, but yes,
we need to get that stuff figured out.
So I don't know if anyone has any additional thoughts.
I liked, I liked having a stipulation that, that, that they need to have a
presence in the city. Some have that, some, some don't.
Some have it like really, really spelled out, and others it's just just
kind of a general statement. So I like specifying that it has
to go to a project that specifically is done in Eagle Mountain, not just
somebody who functions in the area. That is a big deal, yeah. So I
think that was a good stipulation that I saw. I prefer,
personally, my personal opinion, I prefer not to
attach percentages to it so that we have the
freedom to move between Between projects. Between the projects.
Because what if there's like a really killer citywide project
that's 80% instead of 70%, right? Or what if
there's a really killer community-based organization
that what they're doing is really going to have an impact across the city and
it's more than 30%? Like, I just think that— Are you talking about the buckets
of money, 30%? Are you saying we'd only fund 30% of
it. She's saying don't limit the— I don't want to limit, here's how much we're
going to pledge to the city versus here's how much we're going to pledge to
community. I think let's have an application process
and a criteria for judging and judge based on
the criteria rather than being bound. Ultimately, it's all going to flow
to the council anyway. That's right. That's right. I think if we just come up
with the biggest, best That's right. That's how I feel. And— yeah,
hang on. I lost my
train of thought for a second. Well,
one thing that I was gonna say with applications, you should ask how many people
this project will serve. Yes. You should ask how many volunteers are
involved in their organization. You should ask for their very specific plan of
how they're gonna acknowledge wrap funds in their thing.
Yes, and we can have them— like, some cities
do it where we have to, like, we put in a certain amount of
money and they have to match it, um, and things like that. So we just
need to really nail down what— And I just
wonder if some of that can be dependent on the type of organization. For example,
if we have a 501, maybe we have it do matching funds because
You know, I think the hard thing with that is some of them don't have
funds to match, especially most of the nonprofits in
our community don't, don't have staff. Okay, they're just really— And I don't
think we should do matching with our community ones. Like, for sure, it's a neighborhood
wanting to do something in their park. I, I don't think that we should require
matching funds for that. So I don't know, do we ask the city to
do matching funds? Because the city funding— these funds are city funds. So just so
we're clear, it's already— wrap funds is already matched.
So we need to determine at least,
like, I don't know, was anyone able to go through and pick out things they
didn't like from the examples that were given or things they— problems they had?
And when, Steve, should we have this solidified?
By next year? We were talking about definitely by January.
Yeah, because then early next year we want to start. And then we— because not
only do we have to have the criteria, but we've got to have like a
way for them to come in and apply. When they apply for these funds,
it's going to be coming in like basically presenting to us, probably.
Yeah, because they— yeah, they, they usually do a presentation. They've simplified the process a
little bit though now. Like when I applied for council,
there was a form where any— all of you filled that out for you to
be on the invite. I feel like just a simple
one-page or two-page application.
I think, well, give them some space to expand.
They would attach some information to it, or sure. And it's, yeah,
they would need cost information. As someone who's written
grants and also reviewed grants and approved them, I think it's good to
put enough into your application that helps to standardize it. Yes. Because some organizations
really know how to play this game, and others are just really great
organizations that haven't ever dipped their toe in grant water, and I don't want
any of these funds to not be possible
for those inexperienced groups. So if you make your application enough
to be able to get that information that you need out of all of them
in the same way, then it will be easier for And that's
why I don't want to have like percentages. I don't want to count somebody out
that it could really help them out, but because we've already hit our
quota. I don't disagree with that, by the way.
But are you, are you really gonna give— so if we, the whole city
gets WRAP tax funds, and we're gonna say all
of these people applied but 80% goes to this one project,
is that what you're No, I would. I know, I just want flexibility
to all the other— what I'm, what I'm saying is I want flexibility.
And I think you can have the best. It's just what the best price does.
Yeah, like I— But there are others that don't. So she sent out like 5
different cities. And some have actually— Lehigh, I think, was the only one that had
a percentage. And so I know, I should just— I'm not saying
that I want 80% to go to one I just want to be
able to look at the projects and judge them on their merits rather than on
a quota. And we don't— I mean, we'll have to look at the cost,
but I don't know how— It could be like this NOA—
just hear me out, hear me out, all the options before
you roll your eyes. But the group that wants to build this rec center,
you know, what if they came and asked for— they're going to put
in X amount of dollars and $200,000,
you know what I mean? There could be big projects like that that I think
would be worth considering, and maybe that's our one shot for the year to do
something big versus spreading it out on a lot of little things. Yes, and that's
why we've got to make sure this— the criteria, the rubric is
really— Well, and the hard thing with a project like that is some
groups we would not need to ask this to, but if we were going to
do something with NOAA, I would want to know what's it going to cost citizens
to come and take part at your facility.
Well, you should ask everyone that. So if an orchestra comes and asks for you
to fund— How much are you charging? Their space that they're going to use for
their concert, you should ask what the tickets are going to cost. And I think
it'd be similar, like when they come and give us a presentation,
we'll then have the option— They're going
to have to provide you guys budget information. No, the other thing too is we
don't have to spend— and this is something council's gonna have to decide— but we
don't have to spend the whole chunk of money that comes in a year in
that year. There's been talk of like at City Hall we're
gonna want some of those funds to be reserved so we can do arts projects
and different things at the new like City Hall complex.
So like we as a council may say we're gonna put
20% into savings because we want this to go toward
a really big thing that the city has plans for. Are there— there are
some state requirements for certain kinds of funds about how much you can hold in
reserve. Are there any limits on that for wrap tax?
I think it has to be— I don't think we can bank it because— We
absolutely can because I asked Ben about it. Oh, we can? Yeah, we absolutely can
bank it. We just have to use it— like, we have our window
of time. Because initially my idea was, why don't
we just build a big foundation that's kicking off dividends every
year? Yeah, we can't turn it into like an endowment, but we can say we're
gonna build City Hall in 5 years, so every year between now and City Hall,
we're gonna set aside 10% of our RAP tax
because we know that we're gonna want to do some really cool big things there.
Like, that's something that we can do. We just can't create an endowment.
Because he's thinking big, like let's fund
this in perpetuity. Yeah, it just kicks out dividends every year.
Yeah. Well, will there need to be a deadline then of,
all right, applications open January 1st, we need all applications by January
31st, and we are going to spend however
much money from the RAP tax, and we need to decide in the month of,
you know, February what we're proposing, and then
it's done. We don't have any more applications the rest of the year
because we just spent all the money. Well, and I wonder if we could keep
applications open longer, but that this is the deadline for
it and this is when we're gonna review it. We review them once a year.
Well, and there's nothing saying that you can only review them once
a year. You could start with one grant round in your first year, and you
could get to the point where you We do grant rounds every quarter. Like,
there's— and we're gonna have a crap ton of WRAP funds eventually
because we get sales tax on all energy
that's used as well. So like, as soon as the data centers are like completely
up and running, it's gonna be gangbusters for the WRAP funds.
So, and back to Charlotte's thing about not denying a
big project, you should have a tier request of like, this is how much you're
asking, this is how much you're asking, And this is something and above,
and when someone comes in and asks for the something and above, there's a higher
bar, you know, like there's different criteria, like all that stuff. So like,
I would just say set your, your system
up in tiers because that's the way I've seen it. Because I wouldn't want to
do a regional project that uses that many, that much of the funds,
right? It would need to be a full— And it has to be like a
razzle-dazzle. It has to be something that you guys completely believe in, and then the
council completely believe in. But I think there's kind of that dream big
tier where people can come in and ask for something, because maybe there
is a business out there that would come in and run and do some of
those things, but they need the city support in this way as the seed for
it or something. So can RAP tax dollars— RAP tax cannot be
used as a— as the continuing
costs of things, right? So like No maintenance.
Okay. Were you saying that priority to
projects and groups within the city? Absolutely. That's what Charlotte
said. Because there— so if you look at the list of people who applied to
Lehigh, there was a theater group that's like in Midvale,
but somebody in Lehigh lives there,
and they wanted Lehigh to donate that because like 2 people in Lehigh
go all the way to Midville, and I was like, hard no on that.
Like, to me, it has to be in the Cedar Valley or very specifically— We
already have for CDBG, we have groups coming in from other places. That's creepy.
Yeah, and ones that don't even have their— So weird. Why, why would you
go to somebody else's community asking for that? Because that's how they survive. Those suckers
bring in millions of dollars every year. So is that why, is that why the,
the cat and dog rescue thing is, is wanting to
come in No, there's— every year in City Council,
we probably get 40 emails from people that live in our community that don't
want us to go to a no-kill shelter. So it just is— it's a passion
project for them. So I think it's more to do with that than anything
else. I was just wondering if you meant that we were going to get an
application for funds. It doesn't apply. There's nothing about that
that has anything to fall under that. Sorry. do, I think this
has given a lot of thoughts to think about. I think we can— What
if we put this as the first item on the next meeting's agenda?
Yeah, so I was— I think this is gonna be something we need
to talk about every agenda, so I think that we just keep thinking about it
and like share things throughout the
month. Like there's nothing that says we can't, like,
at least discuss some ideas, right? Because I looked at this,
I looked at the summaries, but I didn't pull up their actual applications
because we're gonna need to do that too. So maybe we just dig a little
bit deeper this next time. And what if you guys broke into every
month, there was a chunk of the application process that you drilled down into?
So maybe one of them is the forms that you fill out, the other
one is what the reporting process would be, like Yes.
And what the tiers are and stuff like that, like criteria.
If you guys figured out 6 months worth of stuff, I think you
could have a killer application process and it won't feel so like
all over the place when we're talking about it. So what's the first thing we
should focus on then? Let's start, let's start with the application. Well, actually, I think
you should do the application. Like, I think you guys should say what are the
projects that we want to consider, like what types
of projects and find little buckets that you, you're looking at them to kind of
help people. You should do the application at
the end after you've worked out all the kinks of the process and what you're
asking for. Um, oh my gosh,
they're weird, but they're so much more comfortable than the old ones. So,
um, I think if we— Can you
start with like an AI one? I did. She did. Yeah, yeah, we have.
I don't know if I did. I sent it to you too. I sent you
all of it. So really focusing on the criteria and the,
and the types of projects that we— Well, I'm like, because we
probably need a separate— we do need a separate— I feel like it needs to
be separate for Parks and Rec versus— We need
a city versus community. City versus community, Parks and Rec versus— I
don't know. I don't know if you guys are gonna do an application application process
for city stuff though. There has to be some— we have to have something
for recommendation that we still have to have that same information.
Okay, but it would be different. We wouldn't have to provide— that's
why I'm saying it needs to be a separate process or
a separate application. One application, but it's conditional based.
Okay, what was that? Sorry. We're just gonna have like a condition-based application.
Yeah. But then we
need, like, is it gonna be— you can't
weigh an arts project or an arts grant the
same as you would a recreation. Okay, so you're
gonna want to set up a rubric, and some of the things will be the
same between recreation or parks and arts. Yeah, like how many people is
it serving, how many volunteers is involved, that kind of thing. But then
you'd have a scoring set so that the scoring set— yeah,
everything that gets over like 80% will have them come and present,
you know, something like that. That's another thing, because if we
score it, if it like comes in and we score them individually ourselves,
because we're each gonna have to score them individually, if it's not even worth
our time— Yeah, when we did the match grant,
each of us scored them separately. We came to a meeting, reviewed all of
them, went through what the scores were, and at the end of that night we
knew who we were gonna have come present to us. Okay,
so yeah, why don't we over the next— for the next meeting we can
go with what we think would be the easiest
to start with. I feel like it's chicken and egg. I know, I know
you said we don't want to start with the application, but like We'd have—
we'll have to come back to it either way. Like, whatever we start with,
we're gonna have to come back to. But we don't know what questions we need
to ask on the application until we have the criteria. Well, maybe start
with rec because that feels the most comfortable for some of you guys, and then
after you figure that out, then take what the criteria is going to be for
art. Because we have a public arts code that
we should make the application comply with that. So maybe rec's the
one where you have a little bit more latitude to kind of figure
out how you want it to be. And after you've hammered that out, then we
just apply that to the arts code. So what I would say then
is that through the stuff that I sent you guys,
there's like— there
are rubrics in there. Go through those
rubrics. And we should decide, like, at least on the Parks
and Rec one, if we like,
like, how, what we think needs to be added or taken away or changed.
And then we can get that through. We don't have to, like, assign points
to anything yet, but we can kind of start with that. Okay.
And just what to look for in those projects. And if we think more things
need to be added, you can do more research or look into other cities.
I think there's links to all those cities on what I sent.
So that would be a good place to start. And then we
can't— that's a good idea. We can just nail down at least Parks and Rec
and try that. And I mean, that may take more than one meeting, but that's
something we can start with. And Liz is like very well-versed
with the arts because that's her wheelhouse. So like when she's back,
like maybe she'll be able to chime in with more stuff for you guys.
And the parks one,
are we, are we lumping,
um, communities that have, uh, like neighborhoods
that have a piece of city property in their backyard that they want to do
something with, are they lumped into the same category as
the city that wants to do something with their parks?
No, they can't. I think that the city has to have the autonomy to
say, here's some projects we want to work on and have you guys review them.
I don't think that they should be judged against the
community stuff because there's such different criteria,
right? Like, we look at it, we're like, we've got to put up trail markers
because we have specific things that we're doing either way as a city. So I
think that focus on what you're going
to ask the community to do, figure out the basics of information that you
need from the City Council. Because even if you guys— well,
I just think they're different animals. So start
with community. The community-based. That's what I was trying to
get at, is are we trying to figure out what the rubric is for a
city project, or are we trying to figure out the rubric for a community project?
Why do you think it will be different? Because I think the city— I assume
the city will come to us with, yeah, like, we need these things.
And I don't know that we'll be in a— I mean, will we
be able to say no to those things? I don't— We can
put something in a higher priority, but they're going to make the decision. Yeah.
Well, and the thing is, is if this— if you guys don't want to fund
it with WRAP, the city can always fund it with the rest of the budget.
So— But you will be— yes, you will be making a decision. Yeah, you're going
to recommend to the council. Anything that gets paid for by WRAP
funds, the city doesn't have to cover. So either way, the money gets
spent. That's exactly what I was trying to say without
getting to it. So hopefully it will be some projects just won't meet the
criteria in the rubric and you'll recommend denial. Right.
And others, you just have to prioritize and try
to figure out. Now, will every application application still go before council too?
Like, will they see— at least get a— I think so.
Yeah. Okay. So we need a— even if we already did that, we need a
report. We need a form for our recommendation
as well, one that says we recommend— we reviewed this,
it doesn't meet this criteria, therefore we didn't—
like, we need to be able to explain to them why we denied it if
we did. And you need a process for telling the organization
why they were denied and encourage them to apply again.
Here are some ways that you could improve it, because that's where the match grant
went way wrong. Well, I think this is smart at the bottom
of how it doesn't say denial. He's very good. Yeah,
defer or revise. I like that. Yeah, defer or revise.
Then there's no real denial. Because it's like it's a strong match,
it's good, Partial, deferred, revised, do not recommend.
Yeah, I think this is a good, at least a good place to start.
Which city had that one? This is just the— this
was based off of the— this was rubric example number 1.
Yeah, and that's just not really a city,
based on different things that worked in other cities and what
would be best for what AI thinks
would be best for our city. So yeah,
I think that's great. So next time we'll come, we'll have it on the agenda,
and we will discuss scoring Parks
and Rec.
Did anyone have anything that they needed to bring
up or any concerns? Any comments?
Questions? Are we going to go back to the farmers market again?
Do we need to set a date? Well,
or question, are we going to go to the back-to-school
night too?
What all do we have to— I mean, we've got the bingo card. We can
always gather information about, like,
What people think, I don't know. You have pretty good data on your— that
website you built. The app?
Yeah. I mean, yeah, stuff we've gone over,
but I haven't gotten new stuff. I mean, we could do it from a— we
could go from a viewpoint of safe routes to school,
like where are the issues in your community,
in your neighborhood that make walking to school difficult.
We need speed tables.
I need some speed bumps. I'm going to smile until later.
Did you— were you able, Steve, to get the
feedback that was gathered from
the— I want to say the open space? Oh, yeah, we talked— I actually talked
about that today with some staff this morning. I want to gather
that feedback from the Parks, Trails, and Open Space Master Plan. They did a survey
and they did some— they did an event.
They were at one of the events at the park.
Shopfest. And they got a bazillion people. And I told them
that the parks were labeled wrong, but that's fine.
I'll gather that and share that with the— I'll send it out to the group.
Okay. Because I think that will help as well, because we've
talked about, should we do a survey? Should we— and we talked about that this
morning too, is we'll do a, uh, our annual citizen
survey, citizen satisfaction survey.
But, um, as far as the parks one, Parks and
Rec projects, I think this data will help a lot.
So take a look at the data when I send it out, and then we
can decide, okay, do we, do we need to gather more, right, or is
this sufficient and we know what the community wants in general? So my
question is, if we go to the August 1st as opposed to the farmers market,
what is our purpose there? At the farmers market, we're handing out the bingo cards
and handing out bags and spreading awareness of our group
and of the activities that we're doing. If we go to the
August 1st What is— what are— what's our booth for?
I'm not saying we shouldn't go, I'm just saying what is the
purpose of the booth? What are we doing there? Is it a different audience?
Is that— It's, it's a different audience. You have a lot of, I would say,
focused around, um, like you had mentioned,
how kids are getting to and from school. Like, for example,
over here there's kids on that
live in whatever, Pioneer Edition or whatever that neighborhood's called
over there, their safe route to school is actually
along the side of Eagle Mountain Boulevard where there's
no trail system. The city can't connect the trail because it's not owned by the
city. So projects like that would be good for you guys to identify and
then see how— But we can't fix it either if that's the
issue, right? No, but we can— I think that if we had a stronger
presence we can help with the safe route and reroute the
safe routes. So, so would it be one
where we want to use our QR code to our app and let them
report issues? Yeah, yeah. Do we still have
that, that A-frame? No, let's lose this A-frame.
Um, I have A-frames if you guys have— do
we still have the poster? Yeah, you're welcome to What size does it need
to be? The material inside of it? I will email you that.
What's the, what's the attendance at this event? Last year we
had 2,600. So 2,600.
That's probably more than the farmers market. Do we know what
we're pulling in at the farmers market? If we've looked at it, we should have
that. So August 1st is a Saturday. Is it in the afternoon? Is that what
it is? From This is Marie's
event, so I'm not exactly sure. I think it's 3 to 6 PM. It's in
the evening. We do— you can also set up a booth
on Saturday. I know that's fairly like it's coming up quick and
you wouldn't have like any, you know, anything, but that's a
huge event. There's a lot of— I'm unfortunately moving my
son that day, so back to school.
city event. You know what though, Charlotte, too,
there are other people on the board, so you can move your son.
I don't feel like you have to do every one. Well, this Saturday, yeah,
this Saturday. But the August 1st one,
I could, I could make it to that one. Cool. Charlotte's our salesman that goes
out and gets people to come. She really knows how to work a crowd.
Middle schools as well. Okay, perfect. A school like Cedar Valley will have
a whole administration thing. You're not a front person. You know, we could
hand out our bingo cards, that would work out just fine too, but then we
just have the app. We wouldn't need the bags for that day. Do we
have any more bags? I have 2 cases at my office too.
We should bring some of them. If you don't use all of them, we should
bring the rest to Shopfest and pass them out at Shopfest. I can save the
2 cases I have.
Question, is it too much of a conflict
of interest and not a good idea to put Community Services
Board next to my Student Council at Shopfest?
Nope, that's the whole point. It's a nonprofit role. Would that be a problem
for me to be bouncing back and forth? No, I don't think so.
You're not exchanging any money, it's just info booths.
That's the whole reason why we have that nonprofit role. We can make a shirt
that says Student Council on one side and Student Services
on the other. We're gonna make you change like Superman. We'll set up a little
phone booth. In the morning I can just be with my backpack. 6 to 8.
Okay, so really evening. I was way off. So,
okay, so we are meeting at Cory-Wren. If possible, if you
can't go, it's fine, but if possible, We'll go to back-to-school night to
gather information and try to— the angle can be
safe routes to school. Is everyone on board with that?
Or at least okay with that? Yeah. I can make more— Because
that is a city requirement, right? City works with the school board to
ensure safe routes to school. Is that the way that works? It's technically
the school's legal responsibility. But the cities, they always
dump it on us. We have to figure it out. They just drop schools
wherever they want. Yep. Yeah. When you shot that?
September 12th. All right. Was there anything else anyone had
to bring up? See if anything else we needed to call?
No, I think next— oh, just a note that if we didn't mention it earlier,
that we did meet Councilmember
Clark was there, Charlotte was there, Jesse was there to talk
about volunteer, volunteer program
and policies. And we also had— Don was there,
right? At our volunteer meeting.
Yeah. And communications. So our interns,
Ethan and Addie, our management interns, are working on Drafting
something, and then we'll report back to the board at some
point in the near future.
And then we should— the rules
of order procedure to allow for remote participation, if we could—
I guess we can talk about that at the next meeting, but so then we
can offer if we're in a bind again, we We can have a remote meeting.
That'll be up next. We have a good setup here now that allows
Zoom or Teams or something else. As long as
we can get it to work. It was just
that cable not working, I think, or my computer, but that system works.
All right. Well, if there is nothing else,
I will entertain a motion. I move that
we adjourn. Second. All right,
Charlotte moved it and both Jane
and Sheree seconded it. All in favor?
Aye. Aye. And the motion is— or sorry, the meeting is adjourned at
8:28 PM. What did I do? I was just gonna say state the time.
You got it. You were so great. All on your own.